pfff
[Musique]
tu as vu ce qui se passe là tout au nom
de quoi tu me parles de quoi la radio ou
à la télé les journaux tout le monde en
face à le truc mais oui ce matin chez
lui au précis m'attend mais tout moment
pas à l'autre c'est foutu c'est que j'ai
vu trois corps gisant aventure à parler
aussi bien sinon mieux si l'on peut dire
que tout le monde messieurs ennemis
bonsoir bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez l'équipe à six mines
d'argent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
j'accueille maintenant nos premiers
invités marianne denicourt et bernard
murat
bonsoir bonsoir murat bonsoir donc vous
triomphez en ce moment dans une pièce de
david hare mise en scène par bernard
murat au théâtre antoine qui s'appelle
la chambre bleue et vous y jouez avec
votre compagnon peut dire votre
compagnon oui bac c 1 vous n'êtes pas
pacsé avec daniel auteuil ckoi pacsés
alors on va voir on va vous en parler
désolé les appelle donc la chambre bleue
on va en parler tout de suite après le
sommaire de l'émission
j'accueillerai ce soir patrick de vision
venons
levin
jules edouard moustic
geneviève de fontenay
lou doillon
10 luxe
catherine
vous allez me l'a expliqué ce que
c'était pâques ses marques et vous êtes
prise par la pièce un point incroyable
parce que vous êtes la seule personne à
france sa part n'avait entendu parler
cette semaine mais ça prouve que vous
êtes dans votre pièce c'est bien non
c'est parce que j'ai pas l'habitude de
ce genre d'expression ces nouveaux pacs
est censé voter on peut se pacser bien
alors vous savez que cette émission donc
c'est trois samedis par mois
on commence toujours l'émission en
regardant ce qui s'est passé la semaine
d'avant
parce qu'il ya des gens parait-il qui ne
la regarde pas l'émission donc on est on
va vous montrer un petit best-of un
petit zapping
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
sur non vous appelez code petit ou au
musée haut musée en premier bon alors
est ce que vous êtes volage je suis
marié donc il est volage chéries chéris
soupa vous êtes
doudou en doute mardi din din din din hm
on m'appelait kitty waimes appelé gras
double parce qu'il était gros peut-être
voilages le bourreau il ya quand même
les mâles et les femelles
je veux bien du chemin dans la vie
sexuelle ce qui veut dire circulez pour
l'évolution moi je suis plutôt attiré
par les femmes aujourd'hui renault alors
aujourd'hui j'ai peut-être pourriez-vous
faire prendre pénétrer être passif mais
avec une femme
voilà ça serait bien j'arrive et je
trouve très belle en ce moment là là
présentement l'a vraiment réseau et les
du sud
c'est normal une portugal la maison il
est chaud j'étais petit j'ai aussi déjà
une presque 40 ans est vrai comme en
fait je baise voilà c'était donc le
best-of de la semaine dernière tout le
monde en a parlé
alors moyenne demi tour bernard murat
donc la chambre bleue au théâtre antoine
avec daniel auteuil votre compagnon on
s'arrêtera là bas un taxes et mise en
scène par bernard on l'a dit adaptation
par michel blanc donc c'est que dès que
des top niveau s'est basé sur la ronde
de schnitzler
alors je vais raconter un petit peu pour
nos amis téléspectateurs la ronde en
vitesse vous vous le savez bien sûr donc
la ronde
schnitzler c'est un auteur qui a écrit
mademoiselle else qu'on a vu l'an
dernier au théâtre avec isabelle carré
très bon spectacle c'est d'après
schnitzler que frédéric raphaël et
stanley kubrick ont écrit eyes wide shut
c'était au départ destinée à être lue
entre amis à vienne parce que c'est un
texte assez sulfureux disons et ensuite
ça a été quand c'est sorti en 21 je
crois que ça a été interdite c'était
interdit alors au théâtre s'était créé
par georges et ludmilla pitoeff en 32 en
france déjà un couple est ensuite
c'était un film de max ophuls avec
simone signoret danielle darrieux et
gérard philipe
alors le texte je le disais de david
hare qui a donc écrit skylight qu'on a
tous adoré l'année dernière et alors
vous avez déclaré bernard murat il ya
sont ans d'écart pratiquement entre le
moment où ça a été situé 10 ans au
moment où s'est joué
à paris maintenant vous vouliez voir ce
qu'est devenue la baisse d'aujourd'hui
vous avez dit vous vous dites en fait il
ya pas tellement de progrès simplement
les hommes sont devenus plus sensibles
et plus féminin non mais vous savez le
refaire dit allen a dit quelque chose de
très drôle là dessus il a dit le fleur
de cette gauche mais la pénétration
c'est vraiment dur mais j'ai voulu dire
en certainement dans cette interview que
en ce qui concernait le moment où on est
un donc là y'avait pas tellement de
progrès dans l'histoire voudriez les
hommes sont plus féminin qu'avant vont
pas bien cousu 25 ans vous me dire en
même temps mais on trouvait les hommes
féminin est-ce qu'il pleure facilement
est-ce qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir une et
non par les consoler même pleuré devant
une femme je pense pas je suis pas s'ils
sont devenus plus faits mineurs y sont
peut-être sensible mais c'est pour ça
que je lui demande son avis parce que
c'est ce que vous êtes devenus plus
sensibles
we are tentacle suis devenue extrêmement
sensible alors la pièce était jouée à
londres
elle était jouée à new york avec nicole
kidman marion de nico et derrière
l'hôtel ont fait le voyage de new york
ils ont pris l'avion ils ont fait 7
heures d'avion et quand ils sont arrivés
là bas qu'est ce qui s'est passé s'est
passé qu'elle était malade et qu'elle
annulait la dernière semaine de
représentations
ouais voilà vous avez acheté des nike et
des cigarettes et vous allez enfin voilà
vous êtes jamais vu nicole kidman racine
kane jour délicieux et si c'est bien
quand j'étais aussi déçu du voyage c'est
la métaphore bruce toussaint pas ou ne
savent pas ouais pendant que je parle
serge khalfon si tu veux pas céder des
photos de la scène ce que va pas encore
de deux reportages filmés se passer des
photos donc le sujet ces cinq hommes et
cinq femmes qui ont tous les
caractéristiques de notre époque c'est
toujours joué par un parent vous par
daniel et vous faites tous les rôles
dans 25 5 chacun c'est donc avant et
après l'amour donc ça c'est un pendant
un moment évidemment vous fait quoi
pendant ce moment où certains on se
parlait avec auteuil ou non non vous
changer oui c'est à dire on allait
savoir ce qu'ils font quand c'est tout
noir - vous savez d'abord c'est très
très court on a des changements de
position ces bons riffs un changement de
position et donc il ya le
ces scoops donc lorsque très bonne idée
marianne me disais tout à l'heure en
coulisses que c'est unis david est un
puceau formidable c'est l'idée du temps
certes le temps que dure l'amour est
affichée donc en nationale 1c deux
heures et quelques il y avait eu ces
cinq minutes 0-0 absolument absolument
alors vous vous dites finalement j'ai
moins de scrupules quand j'emploie d'un
couple comme ça parce qu'on va voir mais
c'est un spécialiste mais vous dites
j'ai moins de scrupules à mort et 200
brasse et oui c'est vrai en même temps
oui enfin non mais y'a légal pour et le
contre il ya les aspects positifs et
quelquefois il peut avoir des aspects
négatifs là c'est pas le cas et et c'est
vrai que ça aide beaucoup pour
travailler ce genre de pièce à être que
les gens se connaissent ils se
connaissent pas du tout ce que plus
difficilement ci se disputer entre eux
imaginer qu'elle est engageant la cancer
matic dans la vie ça devient dramatique
sur scène on oui mais heureusement ça
n'avait pas été exactement le
sérieusement vous jouez depuis combien
de temps deux semaines deux semaines
il n'y a pas un soir vous étiez un peu
en froid comme ça j'avais une semaine
c'est bien il ya quinze jours sans
discuter c'est bien non parce que ça
doit être terrible après de faire
semblant
alors c'est un spécialiste parce que 88
vous aviez déjà daniel auteuil excusez
moi avec emmanuelle béart
c'est quoi la pièce la double
inconstance de marivaux ne me regardez
pas comme ça comment je vois franchement
il vient d'avoir parlé de ça aujourd'hui
bah oui très bien auteuil baer c'était
quoi j'ai pas entendu avec la dengue on
saura demain se dérouler
pas du tout alors il ya eu aussi arditi
et willy sinon quoi oui dans le mari la
femme et l'amant mais là je jouais le
mari donc on a été trois essais le passé
c'est pas pour mieux surveiller son
conjoint professa dieu merci non bon
vous avez pas là elle surveillée d'un
criminel oui bon d'accord vous savez ils
ont ils ont un autre phénomène c'est que
comme il joue cinq personnages chacun et
daniel me disait l'autre jour qu'il
avait l'impression de tromper sa femme
avec 4 à 6 ans il y avait la pression
les infidèles à la personne fois dévissé
lundi son rôle avait respectivement
alors vous êtes rencontrés dans passage
à l'acte est un titre prédestiné donc de
francis girod
vous l'avez laissé un peu ramé daniel
auteuil non à vendre le nom c'est bien
qu'une jolie femme le laissera main mais
oui mais c'est pas moi qui ai dit ça
c'est un journaliste qui a dit ça je les
laissais ramé écouter ya oui ou non
enfin combien de temps combien de temps
avant d'accepter de dîner avec lui je
m'arrêterai là je veux pas être un coup
quelques semaines quelques ouais il a
ramené trois mois mais bon on va écouter
c'est normal ah non non attendez moi
tout le monde rame ray des mois et des
années de nikos était c'est évident avec
les toilettes donc ensemble de lawson de
crissements guez et puis vous venez de
tourner ensemble encore ou quitter plus
là au nom fait s'était étalée sur quatre
ans tout ça mais en face à idra vous
devez vous êtes en train de se savonner
en train de sable de benoît jacquot
je vais des scènes un peu partout la nie
tout en fait voilà je vous en mettant
des plus grande que lui pas du tout
parce que sur scène par exemple pourquoi
bien de deux têtes
je ne dis pas le relais à deux cent
seulement des 5 centimes vous êtes
engagé par avait porté des talons plats
toute votre vie non en fait le fâche
porte des talons même dans la pièce
portée puisque les hommes aiment les
grandes femmes souvent les victimes mais
comment ça non plus qui serait
complètement mesurer combien 1 m 75
tout est possible vous avez dit là la
seule chose qui m'inquiéterait vraiment
dans la médiatisation c'est qu'on fasse
des photos de moi en maillot de bain moi
je vous ai vue à poil sur scène donc
voilà toutes les filles peuvent aller se
rhabiller
franchement quand on voit les avait pas
vus on la voit pas dans le paiement
n'ont pas omis comme je gardais un
maillot de marpent toutes les
répétitions il me disait mais de toute
façon tu parles pas et vous allez voir
il ya envoyé par erreur j'ai fait une
gaffe bien sûr théâtre antoine
bon vous avez pas de souci à vous faire
pour le maillot de bain vous d'accord
formidable c'était difficile pour vous
quand vous avez rencontré daniel auteuil
parce que c'est quand même un acteur
très très star en france en plus si
c'est se protéger tout ça enfin il est
très très fort là dessus c'est difficile
au début mais justement parce qu'il sait
se protéger parce qu'elle est très
secret c'était pas difficile du tout
d'accord et est ce que vous pensez que
ça l'est resté longtemps ensemble de
pouvoir supporter rio récompense ça
ouais enfin on en a envie l'un et
l'autre donc c'est joli maintenant que
la ville avait annoncé à priori c'est
fait pour c'est con je sais conçu pour
durer la sphère bas c'est à dire c'est
conçu que pour le moment on a envie de
rester ensemble à voir si vous quittez
dernière question rassurez vous si vous
quittez
si je quitte tu daniel télé vous quittez
ici s'en aller avec une autre fille
d'abord je pense que je le verrai venir
parce que y aurait probablement des
raisons pour qu'on séparés puis sim qui
tu es là maintenant je pense que ça me
ferait de la peine c'est sûr mais je
crois que c'est pas dans ses projets
enfin comme vous êtes tous les soirs à
la scène ensemble il aura pas le temps
d'avoir beaucoup
l'assassin pas facile fois qu'ils
attendent quelques mois alors merci
beaucoup
bernard murat c'est à vous maintenant
vous avez été un facteur longtemps mais
longtemps vous avez joué dans les trucs
insensés
je veux dit oui je ne sais pas s'ils ont
des copains avec l'artiste
on l'a fait on a fait le premier
feuilleton français ça allait mais je
suis très le chevalier bayard oui ça
jusque là ça va
mais alors quand même et en 63 ans 63
j'ai fait la ronde non saisine 3 et j'ai
fait qu'est-ce que j'ai fait d'autres en
63 j'ai dû faire un truc avec molinaro
non avec celle là c'est ce à quoi bon la
bce ne s'est pas aidé du tout je
rectifie la vérité pas du tout non non
non l'année du bac c'est un film qui a
été tourné par josé andré lacour ça
devait être en 62 et l'auteur et le
réaliser l'autorisation il y avait tout
paris qui avait fait le casting et sur
500 jeunes comédiens j'ai été choisi
avec elisabeth génère donc j'avais passé
l'agrégation là ces temps de faire le
film est un conte en ont et sheila que
j'aime beaucoup par ailleurs parce que
je les ai connus à cette occasion ça a
été une petite forme de lancement du
film et il lui a fait chanter la chanson
qui chantait il a rajouté au début du
film annonce excusez moi je lis le rôle
principal atout ou pas du tout
dépendamment de ça je trouve que c'est
une femme charmante et et il n'ya pas y
a pas à rougir de l'avoir côtoyé dans ce
film même si c'est pour sa musique si tu
vois la vie tu es ce que j'ai fait un
film encore aujourd'hui suggère pas
gentille avec très gentil en fait voilà
vous avez compris ce que j'essayais de
dire si vous avez compris à ce moment là
que finalement votre boulot c'était ça
et c'était pas acteur et vous dites
j'adorais faire l'acteur je me sentais
même doué mais voilà j'avais pas
d'emploi mais maintenant on joue sur mon
mètre 69 était rédhibitoire non je
l'avais dit
yom et ça c'est pas très intelligent non
non non non j'ai au contraire je me
sentais pas doué moi c'était ça mon
problème c'est que je me sentais doué
pour regarder les autres mais je me
sentais pas durer comme acteur et puis
en fin de compte c'est pas tout à fait
vrai parce que j'ai joué quand même
l'idée fixe il ya sept ans avec pierre
pendant un an et demi avant on avait
créé la pièce de vaclav havel audience
et vernissages et puis j'ai joué pendant
presque un an et demi le mari la femme
l'amant l'année dernière donc je peux
pas dire que l'acteur après est ce que
vous sentez aujourd'hui heureux ou es ce
que vous avez toujours
j'avais dit le rôle de ma vie je finirai
par me le donner donc c'est à dire que
vous n'avez que quelques pages exhaler
toujours aux éditions
non non c'est à dire que j'ai été
frustré pendant très longtemps des rôles
qu'on me donnait comme acteur bon j'ai
j'ai aidé beaucoup de gens à bien jouer
des rôles et moi ofas je vais lancer la
réplique c'était l'autre qui a ramassé
non après c'est vrai que quand je cite
et l'idée fixe de paul valéry parce que
j'avais un rôle avec pierre qui était
vraiment magnifique
et puis dans le mari la femme l'amant le
je crois que le rôle du rôle du mari il
était vraiment un beau rôle donc c'est
vrai que les beaux rôles quand on les
metteurs en scène on sait à peu près ce
qu'on peut faire et ce qui est ce qu'il
faut pas faire voilà donc peut-être que
j'arriverais à m'en donner d'autres on
va voir voilà donc je rappelle le titre
de la pièce donc c'est la chambre bleue
donc au théâtre antoine
mise en scène par bernard murat avec
marianne denicourt et daniel auteuil au
théâtre antoine
gvt a été méchant dans cette affaire on
a dit on a mis en avant les missions
qu'ils soient gentils avec elle c'est
vrai qu'ils vous ai dit ça votre attaché
de presse merci de venir chanter avec
moi j'ai dit si tu continues tu te dis
je lui faire une interview truc tu le
fais une interview drucker alors elle
m'a dit tony 30
non mais didier c'est pas la peine on
fait pas d'interview de rigueur parce
que finalement ça s'est bien passé sinon
j'aurais fini nattawut drucker alors là
ça a été terrible pour vous je voudrais
demander une serpillière exemple ce que
vous aimez les chiens marianne denicourt
c'est une vraie question c'est une
question de michel drucker oui est-ce
que cela répondait ainsi drica vous
répondriez suis sûr et je resterai un
peu sidérée d'abord comme tout le monde
un chien a priori je préfère les gens
que les animaux
voilà voilà mais voilà donc je vous ai
épargné ça vous restez à l'écouté
moi je m'en fait je crois vous partez
vous je l'approuvé vertou et daniel l'a
écouté là je sens que je suis entraîneur
je suis un drama désagréable non pas du
tout on a je vais là où je dois aller
c'est à dire retrouver d'année
la murale de rester avec nous je suis
ravi pour rester avec nous je veux dire
pourquoi je tiens à ce que vous restiez
avec bluff parce que vous avez dit une
fois dans une interview le premier coup
de poing que j'ai pris dans la gueule
c'était par un mec d'occident et l'homme
politique que nous recevons ce soir
s'est éloigné depuis des années de cette
tendance politique mais il a fait partie
de l'occident
donc vous allez on va montrer à quel
point la france est réconciliée
j'accueille patrick devedjian
je vais pas vous torturer avec la
rassurez vous un bon c'est pas est ce
que c'était a ouais c'était pas à rouen
le mystère rouen 76 a bondi c'était
avant c'est alors que c'est tout vous
pensez vous dit finalement bon il ya
murat il est sympa on va pas se disputer
à la télé tout mais pour corser un peu
la faire j'ai demandé à mon ami laurent
baffie sur tout
comment ça va très bien on n'a pas
annoncé pourquoi je t'ai pas non c'est
parce que je voulais faire la surprise à
patrick devedjian connais pas et si on
fait complètement portant sur 50 ans que
je sois là mais tout à fait j'ai besoin
de quelqu'un pour rebondir
comment ça va ça va très bien j'ai des
dossiers je sais tout tu sais tout bon
par exemple est ce que tu sais que
patrick va désormais publier un livre ça
elle pensait la droite je les lui il
serait le genre de pensée la droite
voilà bien écrit et beaucoup de steve
j'ai passé un bon moment je déconne pas
bon parce que je ne reconnaissais plus
ma fille rue principale adversaire
s'appelle delevoye vous intéresser un
peu saint bernard dans wii il ya
devedjian madame r certains concurrents
voilà concurrents il ya alliot marie en
mia bulté qui et ibéro maoïstes c'était
intéressant comme un personnage un oeil
amusé au pas par celui-ci jean capin non
pardon il est gentil et sympathique mais
c'est devenu notre copain museau sa vie
on a un copain marseille maintenant 1 1
il est sympa mais sont attendus à
marseille nous ont dors chez toi
maintenant
bon alors delevoye lui il est soutenu il
est aidé par pandraud dépendront pour
vous c'est tout ce qu'il faut plus faire
pendre au pont c'est la vieille garde
c'est une image un peu ancien du rpr oui
moi je préfère avoir une image plus
moderne
je viens [ __ ] difficile non c'est pas
dire déjà vous donner beaucoup de mal
tout seul mais c'est vrai que quand on
en rajoute encore the doors bon et puis
en plus de le voir votre concurrent est
pas votre adversaire
il est sénateur parce qu'il n'a pas été
lu aux législatives et lui les sénateurs
il est peinard et pendant ce temps vous
vous colle t l'assemblée nationale avec
jose pas un petit peu vrai c'est un
petit peu oui
est ce que c'est un petit peu vrai par
exemple qu'est longtemps que le rpr a
pas gagné une ville dans le pas de
calais ça c'est un constat c'est un
constat ils s'adorent saint-benoît aïssa
d'or c'est un bonheur
ça n'a rien perdu de leur père
dans ce sens
cela
oh là là alors bien l'ambiance le
scrutin et sur deux tours en principe et
delevoye il s'inquiète de qui va
s'occuper des urnes pendant là pendant
la nuit du premier jour de vote
maintenant il ya il sait sur un seul
jour justement à supprimer le deuxième
jeu faut avoir pour problème ils ont
confiance
ouais d'accord ouais vous vous êtes dit
finalement si on fait tout en surfant
sur deux jours dans la nuit je veux dire
jusque là nous avions des candidats
uniques
oui alors s'imposait pas beaucoup de
problèmes et pour la première fois il ya
une vraie concurrence est vrai et c'est
plutôt bien
ouais alors ça suppose de prendre plus
de plus de précautions et vous savez
quand on fait des élections normales
dans le pays aussi on prend des
précautions pourquoi on les prendrait
pas nous vous pensez pas qu'on ait
l'impression que la droite finalement
ils sont plus préoccupés de se tirer des
bords entre que william date que le
bataillon damas je pense que ils sont
dans une situation que la gauche a connu
dans d'autres périodes donc je pense que
l'histoire l'histoire tourne mais je
crois qu'ils sont vraiment dans dans la
nasse et que là vous êtes dans un piège
pour pas mal d'années je crois je ne
crois pas parce que moi je crois que la
démocratie c'est une potion magique et
jusqu'à maintenant nous avons souffert
d'une insuffisance attendait dans
l'enquêté mais le mais on se rattrape de
trouver la bonne formule
non vous en êtes où vous politiquement
parce que c'est ballot patrick devedjian
et et on va en parler mais c'était très
violemment anti communiste dans irma
thierry anti stalinien
vous avez déclaré gauthier aucune
différence entre l'allemagne nazie la
russie soviétique
oui et que fait manuel et les cadres du
pc aujourd'hui en france c'est
exactement pareil que les apparatchiks
du rss vous qui avez été que j'ai été
trotskiste vous vous avez été au pc dans
le sens inverse d'abord au pc après 3 2
ce qui lui est alors quand vous entendez
ces jeux parcours tout à fait
conventionnelle je suis je vais finir
dans la peau d'un vieux social-démocrate
consensualité sur la route mais je n'ai
rien renier de ce qui a fondé
ma pensée quand j'avais 18 ans non cela
le shérif c'est très beau vous êtes né
en algérie et la famille de votre mère
était algérie française prend une grosse
une partie mois là et vous vous êtes
élevé contre 182 père était un
désistement la vérité monde agissent
donc c'est évidemment on était prêt à
livrer de faire l'indépendance de la
tunisie
donc finalement vous êtes élevé contre
ça vous êtes j'étais pour l'algérie
indépendante
et vous alors ce qui vous a décidé à
entrer en politique c'est justement en
60 heures à condorcet ça mérite
l'algérie vous pensez que l'algérie
devait rester française
absolument je pensais ça je pensais ça
parce que je suis aussi d'une famille
immigrée familles chrétiennes d'orient
et qui a vu sa liberté se réduire qui a
vu un génocide perpétré à l'encontre de
ce qui est et qui constitue en ligne
rires vous êtes d'origine va vous
habitez votre famille habitait
constantinois parce que monsieur
devedjian ne dit jamais istanbul 1 c'est
constantinople
donc ils acceptaient de dire quand même
si la ctu de turku donc monsieur
devedjian votre famille vient de
constantinople et vous êtes arménien
donc vous dit que vous aviez français
oui la cabra d'origine arménienne quand
vous voyez méric vous pleurez oui qu'on
voyait cela vous dit bonjour voila c est
l arménien a donc vous avez vous vous
avez vu ce pouvoir confisqué j'ai vu la
montée de l'islam intolérante
j'ai vu ce qu'a été le nationalisme turc
ravagée justement la différence empêcher
les minorités d'exister et les supprimer
physiquement la guerre d'algérie c'était
pas la montée liste je me suis tu es
bête et font certes pas la montée de
l'islamisme et bien écoutez ça a été ça
en définitive
ouais enfin on peut raconter tout ça on
prend sur 30 ans pas sur dix ans la
guerre d'algérie c'est pas une guerre
est une guerre d'un duo l'immense
coloniale oui c'est pas est la montée de
l'islamisme je suis les frères musulmans
soient venus après longtemps après mais
c'est une autre histoire c'est
l'histoire d'une nation qui s'appelle la
nation algérienne c'est plus l'histoire
de la mairie française ou de l'algérie
algérie c'est théoriquement vous avez
parfaitement raison je me suis trompé
puisque si c'est ce que vous voulez me
faire dire je vous le dévoile en tirant
aussi d'une certaine manière mais je le
dis volontiers comme disait nisand qui
est plus proche de vous j'avais 20 ans
je ne laisserai personne dire que c'est
le plus bel âge de la vie
mais c'est donc je me suis trompé sur
l'algérie mais il n'empêche que sur
d'autres choses mais oui mais bien sûr
l'histoire d'une vie c'est l'histoire de
beaucoup d'erreurs a bien alors si vous
êtes élu votre grande idée politique en
fait patrick devedjian s'il était du
patron du rpr donc c'est de refaire
l'alliance c'est à dire de faire un
grand parti unique de l'opposition de
cesser votre avis avant l'audi pense à
mon avis alors et c'est une de mes idées
mais ça m'arrange idée on va tomber ça a
marché la première fois pour que voulait
recommencer je veux dire que ça c'est
incontournable toute façon c'est pas
suffisant
c'est le nécessaire mais ce n'est pas le
suffisant ma grande idée c'est de
moderniser le rpr c'est d'en faire un
parti qui soit en phase avec la société
avec le monde tel qu'il est devenu
c'est vrai que c'est drôle ça
on s'était trompé de touche qui voulait
mettre quoi je vais mettre autre chose
et je me suis tombé votre campagne est
un peu désordonné on dit elle est un peu
un peu amateur pourquoi je n'ai pas
beaucoup d'argent
certainement j'ai pas beaucoup d'art
parce que je disais nocturne et je n'ai
que la force de mes convictions c'est
déjà pas mal déjà beaucoup je disais
l'autre jour on peut changer le monde
avec ses convictions et oui je lisais
l'autre jour que vous étiez dans une
voiture qui étaient emmenés à la
fourrière dit d'y aller dans le nord ça
arrive à tous les français
moi j'ai fait rimer oui vous avez plus
de scène je l'échangé non négligeable
vous êtes tombé en panne d'essence dans
taureaux des faillites s'est pas amusé
mais ça part en couille la drogue des
choses arrive à tout le monde c'est vrai
un truc énorme a travaillé tellement que
les députés vivent dans un univers
protégé ben là vous découvrez avec
stupeur et tremblements question carte
bleue et panne d'essence on pense pas où
ses protégés c'est pour autre chose
qu'on pense qu'on en protège aimable
pour le relais en 97 le rpr a reçu 230 5
millions de francs alors vous qui vous
n'avez personne vous qui vouliez pas
issu de rationner qu'il est ou le pognon
là d'abord on paye un loyer qui est très
cher
deux centres ses 215 millions jeudi pour
ma mère maman ça fait quoi 23 milliard
de centimes a quand même un nom pas de
cette nouvelle boutique par des loyers
le loyer non il n'ya pas que le loyer
mais faire vivre un milliard ça coûte
cher
faire vivre un grand parti nomme
attendait d où le podium quand vous
faites votre élection vous donne quand
même une allocation là pour votre
élection chaque la wii la wii nous
allons avoir cent trente mille francs
chacun cent trente mille francs chaque
absolument mais elle est où la
différence
la différence d'abord le rpr c'est aussi
une centaine de personnes qui
travaillent pour lui qu'il faut payer
attendez ça coûte très cher je vous
adore enfin sur les 235 zambie ont
retrouvé les bras samedi je vous attends
c'est pas bon signe non mais attendez je
trouve pas ça louche toi non c'est
malheureusement pas lucho on connaît le
traite
josé maria bien dépensé la tournée des
bars et c'est vite parti
croyez moi c'est vite passé au partant
donc shaitan personnes ne sont 35
millions ils sont 130 mille francs ils
sont six a fait un truc que allez disons
900 mille pages tous les partis sont
dans cette situation c'est la démocratie
c'est normal c'est la république rien et
lui tend à donner une droits humains
c'est parce que je dirais non
c'était la naissance avec le bled
d'après il aurait pu quand même
non tu confonds une bonne can il faut
mesurer combien 1 m 77
ça tombe bien c'est ce qu'il a dit
chirac à sarkozy 1 ils agissent delevoye
lui valent c'est un peu son candidat
chirac un delevoye et où c'est pourquoi
parce qu'il mesure 1 mètre 90 ça c'est
important
il même un peu plus je crois même un peu
plus fait 77 vous croyez que je suis un
peu juste en taille mais ici delevoye et
plus haut il n'y a pas de doute mais n'y
aurait jamais pu être président du rpr
par exemple on peut savoir pourquoi vous
avez voté contre le box ah oui
facilement
j'ai voté contre le pacs parce que le
remède est pire que le mal
j'ai voté contre le pac malema madame
c'est un jeu de mots facile et je veux
la paix attend de vision est facile ça
peut être plus subtil aussi wimax bon je
vais répondre à la question si un gros
lourd on a entendu j'ai voté contre le
pacs parce qu'il institue une
discrimination nouvelle pour bénéficier
de nouveaux droits pour un homosexuel il
faut se déclarer et être inscrits sur un
registre accessibles au public et moi je
pense que la pratique sexuelle ça
appartient à la vie privée et qu'on ne
doit pas être obligé de la révéler pour
bénéficier de ses droits
c'est bête je ne vois pas comment on
peut être contre le fait que à un moment
donné des personnes librement qui
veulent s'associer et n'iront se
déclarer à la mairie que ceux qui
voudront c'est pas obligatoire quand
vous parlez de fichiers c'est un rapt
historique de 7 comme expression parce
qu'on voit très bien à quoi ça fait
allusion
donc c'est irrecevable dire comment
donné il va y avoir un fichier les
homosexuels non il ya un fichier de ceux
qui voudront un moment donné être pacsé
mais ceux qui n'ont pas envie c'est pas
leurs pratiques sexuelles qui va
abandonner les dénoncer s'ils vont pas
s'inscrire
ça les regarde non mais et en plus vous
réduisez d'abord le pacs à
l'homosexualité ce qui est pas là ce qui
est pas la réalité parce que c'est pas
que les homosexuels et deuxièmement vous
réduisez en parlant de l'homosexualité
l'homosexualité une pratique sexuelle
mais c'est faux il ya il
culture homosexuelle existe donc on peut
pas réduire sa la pratique sexuelle
c'est pas simplement de savoir comment
les gens font l'amour qui valait
déterminé socialement donc il me semble
que comme sur l'europe moi j'ai voté
pour maastricht
vous aussi on l'était certainement pas
d'accord sur le texte il ya des tas de
choses qui sont imparfaites mais moment
donné faut bien passer à une étape
supérieure
donc c'est comme sur l'avortement c'est
toujours l'arrière-garde il ya toujours
vous attend que c'est pour ça que en fin
de compte la droite reste ce qu'elle est
et que vous avez quand même pas rompu
avec vos origines c'est que à un moment
je parle politique
j'ai dit qu'il ya un moment donné ça
c'est pas c'est un combat d'arrière
garde
mais pas du tout je suis en train de
vous expliquer actuellement les
homosexuels qui par exemple vivent en
concubinage subissent une discrimination
inacceptable
il faut mettre un remède à cette
situation je suis d'accord la situation
actuelle n'est pas bonne le remède
proposé par les socialistes c'est que
les gens qui ne voudront plus subir
cette discrimination se déclare par le
pacs au tribunal d'instance sur un
registre accessible à tout le monde et
qui permettra de savoir quels sont les
moeurs qu'ils ont choisie en moi je dis
cette chose quand on a le droit
on a le droit d'être homosexuel sans
avoir besoin de le déclarer publiquement
et je suis donc pour la protection du
secret de la timide sinon d'accord n'ai
pas compris
marsh intellectuelle président ah ça
c'est une démarche qui part quand même
de la notion du bien et du mal
je vais tout votre raisonnement il part
de là bernard murat bernard murat disait
patrick devedjian l instant finalement
vous n'avez pas tellement renier vos
origines alors politique politique bien
sûr et ses partenaires ont fait pas
gentil non messieurs les questions bien
mais il a été trop de ski quand il est
jeune moi j'ai été d'extrême droite
voilà bon il ya 30 ans qui sont passés
c'est une vieille guerre civile dit moi
le front national en 92 vous avez
déclaré tant que le front national est
légal il est légalisée qui touche déjà
ces fameux 40 millions par an de l'état
tant que le front national est légal
vous avez dit ça dans le figaro c'est
normal qu'ils puissent se réunir et vous
trouviez anormal à l'époque donc en 92
que certaines mairies interdisent au
front national de se réunir dans des
salles municipales
en 98 vous dites le front national n'est
pas un parti républicain vous avez quand
même changé non mais pas du tout aussi
complet contre le front national n'est
pas un parti républicain je souhaite son
interdiction pure et simple oui dans le
monde alors je vous pose une question
vous après vous répondrai est ce que
vous en faites pas un peu trop pour
faire oublier votre passé non je vous
explique très sympa non moi j'ai été
d'extrême droite je sais pourquoi je
serai obligé de prendre des positions
mais je vous expliquais j'ai été
descendre jusqu'en 1966 en 1966 j'ai
rencontré raymond aron et c'est lui qui
a fait de moi un démocrate
quant à quant au front national je suis
le premier maire de droite
le premier en france à voir retirer sa
délégation un de ses adjoints parce
qu'il était passé au front national donc
j'ai pas de leçons à recevoir
je dis simplement il faut être cohérent
ce si le front national est considérée
comme légale par les autorités de la
république
alors il a le droit à toutes les
libertés prévu par la république y
compris la liberté de réunion
ouais en revanche si on veut lui dénier
le droit de se réunir à peut-être
faut-il considérer que c'est parce qu'il
n'est pas en réalité réellement
république a et qu'il n'est équipe dans
ce cas là il doit être interdite rue
basse et maintenant patrick devedjian à
une interview qui va être faite par
laurent baffie est alors voir si vous
êtes joueur
on bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pensé à faire une interview
dyslexiques tueuse un homme de droite
je vais poser des questions tu va me
répondre en tant qu'homme de gauche 1 et
avons aussi dans l'excès répond moi en
tant que coco tu es un communiste alors
que penses tu des 35 heures si je suis
comme je suis pas d'abord si tu
communiste eut commencé presse par
camara c'est la base c'est élémentaire
camarades ma fille je suppose pourquoi
parce que je trouve même que 35 heures
c'est trop et je voudrais qu'il y en ait
encore un peu moins parce que le travail
c'est l'exploitation par le grand
capital et je n'ai pas envie de
continuer à la subit l'impôt sur la
fortune
je suis pour vos camarades baffie il est
plus dense que je suis pauvre et que ça
m'ennuie qui en a qui soit riche et donc
je voudrais qu'on leur en prennent un
peu pour pouvoir améliorer ma vie côté
alors on pensait que fidel castro tu en
penses quoi fidel castro camara plais
ici
il a dévié mais autre au dos au départ
il était vachement bien tu vois puisque
il avait compris les enseignements de du
camarade lénine et puis petit à petit il
a vieilli et aujourd'hui camarades il
faut que tu saches que le vrai
communisme ces différentes fidel castro
en politique aujourd'hui l'ennemi c'est
qui c'est la droite c'est la droite
c'est devedjian c'est le rpr condamnait
pas quand il s'était très chiant quand
tu es sérieux et respect
mais cédé qu'en l'état la lumière
expliqué
non
le président idéal pour 2002 c'est
robert hue mais c'est pas très réaliste
alors je voterai arlette laguiller plus
concret avec ces tueries
c'est plus sympa tu vois il est en
correspondance avec les masses
populaires
il y avait le 20 mètres qui au poste de
premier ministre bakri bin c'est l'idéal
et puis comme ça bernard murat le
retrouvera sa jeunesse à propos de cela
oui mais j'aime beaucoup
y'a pas que nous alors qu'il ya vous
avez vous tendance quels sont les
chanteurs préférés mais chanteur préféré
j'aimais beaucoup léo ferré et jacques
brel j'aurais pu dire aussi jean ferrat
leny escudero
oui j'aime beaucoup jean ferrat vois tu
pas c'était dernières vacances dans le
gers
moi j'avais au camping de melun bon si
on devait débaptiser les champs-elysées
oui je les appellerai comment toi fête
était au pouvoir du karma
enfin à oui c'est vrai j'ai oublié que
j'étais jeu là je l'appellerai avenue de
la victoire du prolétariat à ses biens
quels sont tes loisirs la lui la
littérature et l'archéologie tape un
petit atelier banderole le dimanche
non non et pour finir comment ils font
pour être aussi con à droite et bien ils
nous imitent
bon ben c'est bien
mais jamais ne fait pas parler politique
avec les il est sympa mais comme il est
chiant quand il parle politique yves en
plus il dit pas où est l'argent c'est
n'importe quoi il est beau la durée
sympa que des conneries quoi c'est pas
le mec a pris l'argent je sais c'est pas
ça fait comme ça
non on continue et on continue alors
cette fois je vais vous mettre patrick
devedjian dans les mains de linda hardy
attention il est un volume d'à mais à
quelque chose qui ondule 1% mais à mr
bean
par contre non non c'est non c'est juste
je sais pas je fais une comparaison
comme ça par contre on peut dire votre
âge oui 55 6 à 55 ans vous faites plus
jeune que votre âge qu'en soit la prison
vous êtes mariée à l'âge de 25 ans est
ce qu'il y ait beaucoup d'autres avant
autre femme parce qu'il n'a eu d'autre
oui beaucoup
combien est déconcertante à marier
puceau quoi personne croire et ça non
mais bon ben vous êtes de la droite un
homme de pour les valeurs de la famille
on peut imaginer que maintenant alors à
quoi avez vous renoncé par amour pour
elle elle trouva pas assez de choses en
tous les cas ils pas à la politique
alors oui je trouve que c'est pesant
enfin elle a accepté avec beaucoup de
courage mais elle trouve que c'est
pesant donc à vous n'êtes pas en
polystyrène mais del a d'autant plus de
mérite du courage s'affichent tous les
excès mais le temps des affiches c'est
fini avant j'en passe
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous
agace particulièrement chez votre femme
et ce depuis 30 ans depuis sept mois et
c'est quelque chose qu'il pensait bien
sûr mais c'est ça elle ouvre tout le
temps les fenêtres partout l arrivée
elle ne ferme pas les portes
alors ça fait des courants d'air et
savent comment tu peux rentrer leurs
terres sans vie mais voilà est-ce que
chez les dvd on se réconcilie souvent
sur l'oreiller sur tout le monde dont
tout le monde quand vous avez
l'impression qu'a fait une faute de goût
vous lui dites aussi ne pas se rendre
compte des commandes et ces voix là elle
trouve
non elle trouve que je ne le biais elle
trouve que ce ne suis pas très recevable
dans ce genre de critique et elle
m'accuse d'être daltoniens parfois en
remanient en matière armani des couleurs
ces biens l'avocat qui parle et je ne
suis pas recevable dans ce genre de côté
comme informé lui téléphoner et pour lui
dire quoi
deux ou trois fois par jour pour lui
dire quoi pour lui dire mais les fous
rires je ne sais pas c'est parfois ses
subalternes je le reconnais moi ta femme
rappelle que kasparov et après les
meetings vous l'appelez rendre vous
coucher il l'appelait oui tout le temps
tous les jours pas tous les jours mais
souvent quel genre de rapports vous
entretenez votre belle-mère d'excellents
rapports avec ma belle mère
le maire est adorable tu me disais
remporter ma belle mère est à doha puis
c'est dimanche alors qu'ils débarquaient
semblait ko ces maudits et c'est l'amour
hors mariage vous a déjà tenté bien sûr
donc on imagine que vous avez beaucoup
de femmes qui vous courent après je n'en
suis pas convaincu mais quand on voit
une jolie femme comme vous par exemple
on ne peut pas s'empêcher de l'admirer
ça c'est gentil la longue date a
décroché de saint patron du rpr
est ce que vous faites dimanche matin 11
heures
généralement la grasse matinée votre
haine non avec une érection paris
laurence écouter la messe pour allumer
la lumière merci bon alors leurs murs
merci je rappelle tout de la pièce donc
ça s'appelle la chambre bleue c'est au
théâtre antoine merci beaucoup
j'accueille maintenant pour continuer
l'émission benoît delépine et jules
edouard moustic soit pas très bien la
musique très bien la musique travers
paris oui oui je vous ai vu à christine
boutin avait laissé partir d'abidjan
vous avez deux ans donneront alors si tu
pourrais je portais un autochtone
d'autres présipauté oui groland
alors c'est pas monaco monde où vous
avez les mêmes caméras ont été on
attendait son discours tient très bien
mais un truc il faut qu'ils gagnent
c'est les pompes à gland quoi ça c'est
je vous le dis oui c'est un peu vous
savez des chaussures avec des petits
clans dessus oui et non ça va un peu
ringard alors benoît delépine vous êtes
michael kael sur canal
tu vois là et christian borde alias
jules edouard moustic c'est vous qui
présentait le passe-plat aps le journal
c'est ce que j'ai comme toi les
présentoirs y les présentoirs et c'est
lors npa 20h20 le journal de 20 heures
20 20 g du groupe du vin du harrach et
l'humain l'adage bas connaissons
[Applaudissements]
c'est une forme
c'est une forme de philosophie qui
dépasse un peu les clivages droite
gauche
ouais mais vous commencez à concurrencer
les guignols avec votre truc non
regardez ça c'était un homme attend ça
c'est les mecs en nous un match on est
tous devedjian il dit pas de mal de le
voit il n'y pas de mal de balladur c'est
normal mais vous vous êtes pareils
finalement non mais ça avance et les
guignols vous dites tueries des comptes
quoi merde sa façon le même les passions
de même plan c'est dans la même tranche
horaire sur la même chaîne
bonjour oui mais c'est pas la même chose
dans un journal amazon et non non
franchement on n'est pas du tout enfin
c'est un raisonnement de droite
justement ça avance ça explique moi
c'est concept droite la droite s'est
imaginé une société en pleine
concurrence etc où tout le monde veut
bouffer l'autre etc etc
et nous on s'en branle complètement
alors votre journal à votre groland que
je montre à la caméra donc c'est un
c'est un vrai guide parce qu'on a vu
alors non parce qu'on a vu un américain
que
un réalisateur américain qui est venu
annuler par ailleurs il a presque rien
dit mais il a montré son bouquin tout le
temps donc on à dire que le bouquin on
va rien d'ailleurs affirmé montrer tout
le temps bien alors on va regarder un
extrait donc du 20h va 21 juin 20 h 20
magnéto serge khalfon s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
d'accord abane présente
inforoute pour demain paco rabanne
prévoit une grosse apocalypse porte
d'orléans un bouchon d'armé guénon à
beaune et 3 km d'antéchrist au triangle
de rocquencourt
pour les retours la journée de dimanche
est classée rouge sang paco rabanne
conseille fortement aux automobilistes
de ne rentrer chez eux qu en 2024
[Musique]
je vous propose un petit tour d'horizon
de l'actualité dans le reste du monde
[Musique]
pour être encore plus partout alain
duhamel a mangé son frère patrice selle
n'avait pas prévu paco rabanne que les
nuages se paie très la gueule visite
médicale pour les policiers new yorkais
ils sont tous prêts pour le toucher
rectal france nombreux ont été les
oiseaux de mauvaise augure qui prévoyait
la fin du monde avant les clips mais
l'apocalypse n'a pas eu lieu
pourtant paco rabanne continue de se
terrer dans un de ces bunkers dans les
alpes
michael kael est avec lui depuis le
début août alors michael pourquoi vous
ne sortez pas de votre abri parce qu'il
me laisse pas sortir important ya pas
une catastrophe
ainsi s'il a plusieurs fois par jour une
nouvelle prophétie oh [ __ ] ça
recommence nostradamus a dit la station
mir a pas convaincu les fans forme
d'élégance et de places qui n'appartient
qu'à nous c'est à dire que nous tutoyons
le bon goût mais on ne sait jamais tombé
bien bas
c'est quoi le groland alors oui je suis
mes couleurs et mélantois
je fais mon boulot eux employés à
tétouan à gauche parle je fais mon
boulot de présenter soit faire mon
boulot c'est mon boulot mon boulot
as tu es bien de battre alors sur un
ancien nazi mais comme ils sont tous
morts alors du groland chez michel lafon
voilà je m'en veux de bouquins 1 comment
ils vont non mais c'est en offrant mais
vachement bien triste sort jeudi
continuaient d'être de droite comme ça
c'est quand on a entendu alors c'est
quoi le groland et bien bas c'est un peu
crétin qui recevra une bouse je pense
qu'il ya la carte quelque part mais
enfin c'est la présipauté là bas valais
le président pauthe est vrai c'est un
système politique assez particulier ça
donne un président qui est auto élus
tous les sept ans il est le seul à avoir
le droit de vote démocratiquement mais
il est le seul à voter bon s'il n'a pas
la gueule de bois normalement c'est lui
qui est lui qu est ce qu elle est si je
peux un peu comme en france
chirac c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser la
question chirac est président et
maintenant il est très bien il est aussi
drôle que notre président c'est un peu
le même genre c'est un peu le même genre
que christophe salengro dans tous les
ont tous les deux un côté joe lewis est
un band mr bean serait très bien placé
pour être le ministre ces chars à ce
qu'il appelait chirac forrest gump lui
ah oui parce que serre des mains ils
marchent tout le temps il arrive au
sommet je suis dedans oh la la qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'à quatre lacs
j'avais pas vu ça j'ai jamais
avec là c'est quoi cette can alors qu'à
quelques claques thierry ardisson non
mais c'est quoi
ah oui allons aider à masquer ces coptes
kadhafi céder il coups fouet ouais bon
cd certainement qui doivent recevoir des
anciennes émissions là bas encore
maintenant et que la nouvelle
tu vas te détendre j'avais été là que
j'ai pas la chaîne hd perdu la face des
trous mais aussi de leurs bleus s'est
redit dans un langage non mais qu'est ce
que tu fous fous et c'est une possession
du groland et avec une faute de frappe
trompait données non franchement il ya
eu des blessés
bah moi je voulais devenir une série de
petites choses c'est de s'attaquer aux
émotions je viens je suis là j'ai lu
comme tout le monde c'est un biographie
comme tous les invités
ouais je me suis dit tiens je vais pas
tellement m'entendre avec lui parce que
effectivement rpr suite balladuriens
fera tout pour me plaire
mais je trouve que depuis qu'il a un
parler publiquement de son homosexualité
je sais on est assez content
mais pas si elle est assez content de ce
scoop c'est pas lui annoncer suis dit
merde
dites-moi quand vous étiez enfin quand
vous étiez à canal combat fille était à
canal vous croisiez vous aimiez bien
mais malheureusement il m'a foutu dans
la merde quand je commençais à parler de
moins en moins à canal il me disait
c'est génial tu était aux premières
loges tu dit pas un mot
pour moi le le compte de l'esthétisme
sais que tu dises plus un seul mot et il
m'a plu dans ce combat sérieuse de l'anc
il a rien fait pendant la sortie
c'est vrai que j'ai souvent pensé à lui
des émissions j'ai dû dire trois phrases
pensez un peu à toi quand tu disais
réaffirmé j'adorais fin mais tout le
monde ne regarde pas la télé après avoir
pu mais c'est vrai oui oui quand on fume
il est drôlement ne peut pas essayer
maintenant quand je n'étais pas du tout
à l'image c'est comme ça que je le
préférais vous regardez la télé après
avoir fumé un pétard patrick devedjian
ne fume pas même pas même pas des
gauloises mais vous devient ce sens de
la fête qui y naissent
alors bon vous avez fait partie des
guignols vous avez déclaré les guignols
ont fait lire chirac en 95 15 jours de
plus et c'était j'ose pas qu'on faisait
bien moi je suis très content que ce
soit chirac soit lassée après cool parce
que ça fait d'être un modèle pour le
groland et plus loin décennies solutions
et du tout on est on est un gouvernement
de gauche mâchant je pense que
normalement l'anarchie a une chance de
vaincre
ouais donc tout va bien vous êtes
vraiment un anarchiste benoît de plus en
plus sont effectivement puisque je pense
que la grâce aux moyens de communication
etc
maintenant les gens peuvent se
responsabiliser tranquillement quoi
quand même moins de moins en moins
besoin de ces hommes politiques qui
malheureusement sont voués à partir et
disparus
vous pensez vraiment que les hommes
politiques vont disparaître non je ne
crois pas parce que ce serait pire ce
sera encore pire
beaucoup de liberté va fair être
gouvernés par des machines
on a rarement vécu dans une société
aussi réglementée moi je m'étonne de son
optimisme parce que plus on avance plus
on règlement tout est réglementé marc
lafosse castres tu vois vous disais le
contraire toi disait le contraire il ya
20 minutes
non mais c'est patrick toi il faut de
prendre deux heures parce qu'on va mieux
il disait à bernard murat attendait une
société de liberté bien c'est
terriblement t mais cela dit on est
beaucoup sur liberté quelques airs
gaulle est alors collé patrick vous avez
jamais votre mariage est encore bon ça
me paraît pas indispensable pourquoi il
cherche la veste ils ont patrouillé la
veste encore mais on va faire faire vous
dites que si on parle ont repassé la
police mais drôle quand même qu'ils
reprennent celles de mr bean mais qui
l'arrangent me trouvez vous aussi bien m
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a invitée dont
l'association for quite à mr bitumeux
demander pourquoi ouais non non bien sûr
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait cherche
kalfon s'il vous plaît baisser un tout
petit peu voilà la lumière jingle
embauche par mois je vous faire une idée
le mans sont justement comment fait
d'habitude à la télé vous êtes prêt
moustiques vers la répondants montant
oui c'est difficile ça se regarde l'air
qui lie la 16e levée le bon dieu sans
confession
est ce que vous êtes content que le pacs
a été votée ça honteux je trouve que les
[ __ ] faut tous les tuer vous êtes
toujours d'extrême droite moustiques
abrite toujours d'ailleurs je trouve que
on peut être homosexuel vous n'êtes pas
seul de déclarer
est-ce que vous avez été heureux est-ce
qu'ils étaient heureux benoît delépine
que la gaffe il est élu personnalité de
l'année aux sept d'or se trouve
seulement un vrai conte de photos et
aussi mais c'est l'interview mensonge un
bernois non non je ne le pense pas du
tout ce que j'aime bien je vous adore la
gaffe à bagua mon meilleur ami ah
d'accord mais qui sait plus votre
émission favorite
j'ai eu mon sens est ce que vous trouvez
que ppda les journalistes oui bon il
incombe aux vaccins
ils arrivèrent de ses cadres sont encore
bloqués non non mourir c'est notre truc
c'est la coke si on a d'ailleurs là je
me sens déjà mince on en attend mais
c'est l'interview mensonge arrivait
justement d'accord on est clean mais
c'est pas possible de table oui j'en ai
bonne place de groland et non mais nous
on est très clair c'est marqué dessus
c'est du vin dû lâcher du vin nous
excuser ses marques il est pour vous la
dépénalisation de la fin du mensonge en
ce qui vous concerne je suis pour une
modification de la législation puisque
elle n'est pas appliquée je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui personne n'est poursuivi
pour avoir fumé nuage en pratique de
silence à wickham
c'est celui ci ça peut arriver quand on
est bien évidemment le principe de
l'interdiction
en soi peut-être compris mais en tous
les cas la pénalisation comme c'est le
cas à l'heure actuelle non appliquées
ouais là pas de sens si benoît delépine
moustiques merci donc vous a bien rendu
votre bouquin la save à eux donc alors
voila voila voila je veux non je n'ai
absolument rien à ajouter rien à ajouter
vos genoux
oui cela on va recevoir quelqu'un
d'étonnant vous avez entendu parler de
philippe ménard
oui philippe ménard là messieurs
[Applaudissements]
il bernard o
trente et un bon soir j'arrivais durera
six mois j'ai les applaudissent que
j'aidais à ploëzal ha richer c'est comme
dans les sitcoms exactement bien
vérifier s'était alors philippe a été
adorable
quand on est avec marianne on passait
dans les loges il disait qu'il ya plein
de jolies filles avant vous êtes en
train de tourner partout csii à
devedjian qui devient archives de fait
jean narcisse ménard hétéro donc
maintenant non mais on peut tout à fait
être homosexuel et ça pour être acquise
au gym
mais ceci dit vous les choisissez très
bien et très même les défis les filtres
bien alors que là on va vous présenter
vous êtes vous êtes un élu de l'udf et
je pense que vous êtes le premier si je
me trompe pas le premier élu de la
droite à faire votre coming out c'est à
dire à dire que vous êtes a été le
premier à dire que j'étais homosexuel
oui jusque là j'ai vu beaucoup de gens à
gauche et vu delanoë il y avait eu
gaspard il ya eu de vraies par ailleurs
le maire de pau et balladur une halle il
est chargé en master i m'a jamais dit je
vous sers et comptait au dernier moment
non sans que sa perche comme un pense
que c'est une passion rentrée de votre
part ma fille eh bien il a nourri la
normale
ben bella deux idoles en politique c'est
assez vrai alors c'est vrai bon c'est
mon moment ça l'a vraiment vraiment
c'est lui qui t'a fait c'est lui qui me
fait vraiment beaucoup et bien par les
leaders by d'or alors que bella
j'avais 29 ans vous êtes adjoint au
maire de barsac en utilisant un petit
bled dans la région de bordeaux dont 20
avec du bon vin
vous êtes arrivé sur le devant de la
scène le 27 août 99 donc à risoul dans
les autres dans l'est dans les
hautes-alpes l'université d'été des
jeunes udf et vous avez interpellé je
raconte un peu comme ça à propos pour
les gens qui vous connaissent assez
encore des gens qui ne connaissent pas
vous interpeller et philippe douste
blazy au sujet de christine boutin
justement en disant mais enfin c'est
incroyable philippe pourquoi l'udf a
choisi une personne aussi radicales pour
s'exprimer sur le sur le pacs mais
finalement ça a ringardisé un petit peu
la droite cette histoire est d'ailleurs
on voit bien cette année sur le pacs à
la maintenant là cette semaine tout le
monde finalement à droite de bons même
devedjian vous n'êtes pas content vous
quand on vient voter contre mais vous
dites parce que la loi est mal faite et
tout ça mais enfin je suis pas homophobe
non pas d'une abaya plus la même
opposition que l'accueil à la dernière
fois que la loi est passée
les homosexuels ont apporté beaucoup à
la culture la civilisation de tout temps
ça a toujours existé n'y a pas de raison
d'avoir des préjugés
c'est énorme à la télé white surtout à
beaucoup apporté à la chance au cinéma
la chanson sûr avec des punks en gros
alors fini vous dites est en gros
christine boutin n'a rien à faire à
l'udf alors philippe douste-blazy quand
vous lui avez dit ça a été un peu
paniqué à la tribune il sait plus très
bien quoi dire il a dit m'attendais
c'est moi qui ai fait le préservatif à 1
franc et oui c'est vraiment faim quand
même vous avez quand même et christine
boutin voilà et alors il a quand même
mis un peu d'eau dans son vin
philippe douste-blazy l'a dit la pensée
de christine boutin est à moitié honnête
à moitié homophobes
ce qui prouve que philippe douste-blazy
et un vrai centriste alors on en a la
preuve avec cette phrase alors la preuve
aussi c'est que christine boutin la
dernière fois qu'on a parlé du pacs à
l'assemblée elle a eu cinq heures et
cette fois ci il a eu cinq minutes
donc apparemment votre action n'a pas
été complètement inutile alors vous vous
êtes à l'idheap depuis l'âge de 19 ans
vous êtes homosexuel c'est difficile
dans une communauté comme
barsacq avec deux mille habitants non
c'est difficile d'autant plus que
depuis un certain nombre de mois
suivant les milieux et surtout depuis
les dernières élections régionales en
1998 élections auxquelles je participais
puisque j'étais candidat sur la liste de
jacques valade qui était le président
sortant du conseil régional est donc à
la suite de ces élections tous un petit
peu précipité pendant la campagne on m'a
menacé de distribution de tracts dans ma
commune dans les boîtes aux lettres de
ma commune tracts sur lesquels devaient
figurer un certain nombre de détails
croustillants sur ma vie privée et ma
vie professionnelle
ce à quoi comme je suis un garçon un
petit peu émotif j'ai un petit peu
paniqué et je me suis dit que à ce
moment là la meilleure des défenses et l
attaque et qu' il n'était pas question
pour moi de céder à ce genre de
pratiques et donc bien évidemment j'ai
maintenu ma candidature aux élections
dans la nuit du 11 au 12 août vous
dormez pas et le 12 au matin votre
décision est prise vous dit cette fois
cette fois j'ai pensé à moi parce que
c'est vrai que votre travail d'élu vous
oblige à beaucoup penser aux autres
vous avez réalisé au chardon je vais
aller à la pêche non cette fois je vais
penser à moi je les plus tricher vous
décidez donc de rendre publique la chose
de façon effectivement aux protégés de
ces menaces présentes des fois vous
écoutiez votre portable comme ça il ya
des coups de feu voilà c'est quand même
enfin c'est la région où ils tirent sur
les tourterelles vont me dire maintenant
ceci dit il n'a pas tout à fait tort
parce que
je me suis effectivement posé la
question première quinzaine d'août de
savoir si ils n'étaient pas mieux pour
moi de continuer à tricher et de
continuer à être cachés et en ce sens de
fuir tout ce qu'ils pouvaient faire en
sorte que j'étais pas bien dans ma peau
c'est à dire j'ai effectivement envisagé
de quitter la mairie de démissionner de
quitter la commune dans laquelle je suis
arrivé j'avais trois jours donc bon j'ai
quand même passé près de trente ans de
ma vie et je me suis dit ben je vais
aller voler vers d'autres horizons et
bon je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais je suis issu d'une famille dans
laquelle il y à cet enfant dans un
milieu agricole puisque mais pendant
sans vidic et les parents s'en sont
viticulteurs on était au courant depuis
depuis l'âge de 18 ans et où finalement
cela n'avait jamais posé spécialement de
problèmes sous les 1 enfant ils auront
des petits-enfants de toute façon il y
en a déjà pas mal d'ailleurs
mais nancy mais il ya eu certains
événements dans dans ma famille qui qui
m'ont amené un jour manche et failli
perdre ma mère à deux reprises et je ne
voulais pas que si elle partait je ne
voulais pas
ne pas lui dire qu'elle était quelle
était ma vie est donc un soir j'étais
étudiant à dax et donc je les appelais
et nous avons profité le week-end qui a
suivi pour pour discuter de ma vie pour
discuter de ce que j'avais l'intention
de faire et donc c'est à ce moment là
que je je lui ai révélé que maintenant
j'arrive maintenant elle va elle va
mieux alors fini donc vous l'annoncer au
conseil municipal aurait dû est alors là
là aussi j'ai donc le matin j'ai appelé
le maire et je lui ai dit je
souhaiterais que tu organise une réunion
des adjoints avant le conseil municipal
parce que j'ai quelque chose d'important
vous annoncer et donc je leur ai annoncé
que je leur confirmer ce que tout le
monde disait c'est à dire
qu'effectivement j'étais homosexuel et
comme nous avions une réunion du conseil
municipal le soir j'ai demandé au maire
qu'à l'issue du conseil municipal puisse
réunir le groupe majoritaire pour que
nous puissions en discuter parce que je
souhaitais que tout le monde le sache
en même temps et
que tout le monde éventuellement puisse
donner son avis et qu'on puisse en
discuter tranquillement
non moi ce qui m'étonne beaucoup c'est
par exemple vous vous êtes là vous êtes
udf vous patrick êtes rpr et donc à
l'intérieur déjà voulait faire
l'association houleux car la wii comme
j'étais nerveux faire l'alliance qui a
tellement bien marché
entre le rpr et de démocratie libérale à
l'époque l'udf qui ensuite dressé
libéral vous n'êtes pas d'accord là
dessus vous vous pensez
parce que lui pense à un philippe vous
pensez vous que la droite aurait dû
voter le pacs ne sais pas s'il ce n'est
pas le fait que les parlementaires de
droite n'est pas voté pour le pacs qui
me gêne c'est pas ça ce qui me gène et
ce qui m'a amené à faire des
déclarations que j'ai faites
c'est les comportements de certains
parlementaires de la droite
moi je suis un être humain je fais de la
politique mais je suis un être humain et
donc quand je constate certains
débordements verbaux je suis blessé
d'autant plus comme je suis concernée et
quand je vois des parlementaires qui
pour passer à la télévision vite fait au
journal télévisé se permettent de dire
les [ __ ] je leur pisse à la raie ou quand
j'ai adoré gaza qu'est-ce que je ne sais
plus vous avez la raison il ya des
vocalises annoncé dans des rafles chez
vous c'est qui c'est un udf mais de dire
son nom c'est important quand on a un
sénateur qui par contre est rpr qu'on
parle pacs à un projet de contamination
sidaïques ouais quand on à madame boutin
qui est dans mon parti il participe à
des manifestations dans lesquelles on
peut lire des pancartes les [ __ ] au
bûcher
et ça ça me choque ça me choque en temps
que les [ __ ] je leur pisse à la raie
c'est déjà ça peut dix ans le mec il dit
c'est bien parce que l'ambiance et ça ça
me changerait est ce qui a motivé à
venir chez vous si je peux me permettre
un philippe ya pire chez vous il ya un
célèbre homme politique de votre parti
dont nous ne citerons pas le nom parce
qu'on n'est pas des balances qui lui est
homosexuel mettait les défilés étaient
les défilés étaient les défilés contre
le pacs oui ils ont décidé qu'ils n est
pas c'est pas le jeu il ya des sépales
avec les chemins l'ena on parle à droite
il ya à mon avis autant d'homosexuels
qu'à gauche il ya qu'on va plus en plus
les états il s'est en outre dit non ce
n'est pas du tout je dis qu'on peut
considérer que c'est un choix de vie
privée qui ne regarde que la personne et
que le pacs quelque chose qui est
destiné à rendre public ce choix et
qu'on n'accepte pas comme tel derrière
l'homophobie c'est une chose condamnable
le refus du pacs c'est autre chose il ya
deux aspects vous parliez de ce député
qui a défilé à cette manifestation fait
moi si vous voulez mon avis sur sur son
comportement je le plains je le plains
parce que quand on est obligé pour
soigner son électorat d'aller manifester
contre contre soi même
ouais contre contre ce qu'on est même si
on veut l'enfouir d'enfouir contre
l'être contre nos propres différences
c'est dramatique ceci dit je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion d'en discuter avec lui et
j'espère qu'un jour j'aurai l'occasion
d'en discuter avec lui et je m'arrange
l'appel dans un bar je me rangerai qu'il
n'y ait pas de caméras de télévision
comme ce soit parce que j'ai pas envie
de lui porter tort mais je lui
expliquerai mon point de vue ceci dit je
ne suis pas non plus pour
ce qu'a proposé act up c'est à dire de
deux forces et j'ai dit sur les gens et
leur coming out série disent eux-mêmes
voilà je suis homosexuel ce que vous
avez fait le premier encore une fois à
droite hommes politiques de droite de
l'avoir fait
soit il ya la balance c'est ce que
propose acte a pas un moment là où thing
c'est à dire on les dénonce
moi quand j'ai entendu donc c'est cette
envie d'act up 2 août et ce député ça
m'a fait penser tout de suite je me suis
remémoré les images que j'ai vu à la
télévision de ce qui s'est passé pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale c'est à dire
que on envoyait dans des camps de la
mort des juifs avec des étoiles jaunes
on envoyait des homosexuels dans les
chambres à gaz avec des étoiles rose et
ces gens on les envoyait la balle sur
dénonciation très bien merci beaucoup
merci de votre témoignage
voici si vous me le permettez rajouter
un mot parce que tout à l'heure j'étais
attendait donc pour venir sur le plateau
et on m'a transmis
un fax des insultes sur lesquels ont
menacé de dénoncer un certain nombre de
choses supplémentaires sur ma vie en
diallo neige était alors si vous me le
permettez gens mais j'ai deux trois
choses à dire il me semble que certaines
personnes n'ont pas compris ce qui a
motivé cette démarche là on ne reproche
d'avoir voulu m'en servir à des fins
politiciennes
je devrai bien que les gens comprennent
que quand on est de droite et qu'on veut
plaire à un électorat de droite
on les dit on dise que les gens de
droite ont envie d'entendre
et on fait ce que les gens de droite en
vie qu'en face et le problème c'est que
je n'ai pas du tout fait ça pour ça je
les fais pour moi et je les fais parce
que j'en ai assez d'évoluer dans un
milieu où règnent l'hypocrisie et je
vais vous dire une chose que j'avais
décidé de ne pas dire parce que je
souhaitais protéger une personne
il ya trois ans j'ai voulu faire ce que
nombre de politiciens font c'est à dire
vouloir mentir et je me suis marié je me
suis marié parce que j'avais le
sentiment que ça protégerait ça me
protégerait de tout ça et je me suis
rendu compte à un moment donné que
c'était pas la solution parce que je
m'enfermais dans un mensonge qui était
difficilement supportable et j'en ai
discuté avec un certain nombre de
personnes il se trouve aussi que je peux
en discuter avec mme amal d'homosexuels
parce que sur bordeaux j'ai des parts
dans un établissement qui est fréquenté
par par des homosexuels donc j'ai pu en
discuter avec eux et l'ensemble des
informations que j'ai recueillis le mal
être que j'ai pu percevoir par ces gens
là le malheur la solitude qui que j'ai
ressenti m'a fait me promettre à
moi-même que dorénavant je ne mentirai
plus que si je fais de la politique que
j'en fais par passion et pour des
convictions et que donc si les électeurs
veulent que je travaille pour eux il
faudra qu'ils me prennent comme je suis
avec mes défauts et mes qualités et je
pense que c'est avec des gestes comme ça
qu'on peut redonner
oui mais là j'ai bien compris que tout à
fait clairement ce que vous êtes en
train de me dire là maintenant vous vous
dites aux gens qui essayent encore
maintenant malgré votre communal de vous
faire chanter vous leur dites donc je
c'est vrai je me suis marié
c'est vrai que j'ai une agence
immobilière à bordeaux et que j'ai des
parts dans un établissement fréquenté
par les homosexuels donc n'essayez pas
de me faire chanter avec ça je le dis à
la télé voilà c'est fini
bravo merci merci beaucoup c'est pas mal
un courageux et 3 jeux parce que il n'a
pas envie de se laisser emmerder il
préfère le dirai bravo je voulais dire
je suis très admiratif de thierry
ardisson parce qu'à chaque fois il fait
d'énormes tentatives pour des ringards
10 et la droite puis à chaque fois c'est
une pelletée de plus
ouais faut arrêter la boîte faut c'est
fini quoi mais lui justement ça l'est
tout il sait moins que ça il a laissé
unis va sonner il se retrouve avec des
électeurs qui est qui qui ne peuvent
même pas comprendre ça qui lui emboîtent
dans les cra de nîmes etc et ce rythme
enfin bon c'est vrai qu'au conseil
municipal
il n'a pas été là mais tout le monde
connaît un franc succès bien mais le
devoir d'un homme politique sert aussi
de la pédagogie
mais c'est ça moderniser ou s'il a droit
en enfer chers amis chers ennemis
j'accueille maintenant celle sans qui
linda hardy ne serait rien
voilà et je ne parle pas de catherine
barma
je parle de madame de fontenay
veut dire qu'elle s'entraînait j'allais
me fontaine et un ami patrick devedjan
quand même apporter ma dernière fois
qu'on s'est vus à la télévision
je lui ai dit si vous enlevez votre
chapeau je m'habille en blanc la fois
d'après avez vu vous aurez autres
chapeaux étaient des corps noir et blanc
le voilà et je me suis donc retrouvé en
blanc pas longtemps la fois d'après ah
oui je suis un mec de parole mois dites
moi un truc là par exemple si vous
enlevez votre chapeau qu'est ce que je
fais voilà je sais pas je n'ai pas grand
chose à faire là on s'est battu comme un
lion blanc vous connaissez donc benoît
delépine nouvel essai judo à moins que
vous connaissez laurent baffie oui elle
m'adore non mais c'est maintenant
attendez moi je suis pour la paix des
ménages
donc je voudrais d'un mec je voudrais en
parler j'aimerais qu'on dise les choses
parce que les philippe ménard nous a
donné l'exemple finalement d'une
franchise hors du commun les bêtises
encore il a fait une boulette il a fait
la boulette chanteur dans les années
60-70 qui gardait toujours son chapeau
qui s'appelle daniel géri le garder
parce qu'il avait un sexe qui poussait
savoir
c'est une forme d'art in flandre
maritime oui c'est le madame de fontenay
quand adam son chapeau et c'est pas la
france entière une érection et je sais
que chez vous ça vous excite mais c'est
quand ça elle peut pas s'empêcher alors
maintenant maintenant non jeu m'a dit
moi ce qui vous oppose la lame de fond
gris vous êtes gérant de fontenay je
trouve que c'est face à des risques
particulière de manifester son ratio je
trouve que c'est l'ambassadrice du bon
goût et j'ai une admiration sans borne
peut être alors on s'est pas l'interview
mensonges parce que l'incident avec nous
je pense que l'orangé d'amis ça y est
oui je suis pas rancunière et moulant
mais maintenant mis en échec
on
la maman images et outreau s m
puisant balade époux
/
en parlant de papier c'est tout sur les
problèmes de fond c'est fini on entend
non non mais l'incident est clos à la
hâte et déniche williams qui boudent
revient mais comme toute bonne
oui et non début d'érection là alors on
attend des dommages alors il est marié
tous les fidèles s'ils me disent ah bon
alors donc l'une des rares dit vous la
connaissez bien miss france 92 qui tient
prêt mais préférait d'ailleurs à votre
avis elle a été élue ch
on se calme la piste cassel a été lu
pourquoi pas vu m'a d'abord parce que
les téléspectateurs l'ont élu oui c'est
pas moi qui ai début parce que l als
compte de ce que vous avez déceler elle
a beaucoup de personnalité là elle a du
charisme et elle est belle les voilà
toutes les qualités
c'est ce qu'elle vous préfériez les
cheveux parce qu'avant mais c'est
sûrement préféré sécher les cheveux
quand même oui mais j'ai pensé je
pourrais venir il faut avec des
extensions mais tout à fait à l'écouté
c'est vrai que ça lui va bien mais c'est
vrai que vous voyez entre miss france
souvent on a chacun on a chacune n'ont
rien mais je suis super heureuse
explique françois deviennent des
délégués organise les élections
wigan a beaucoup changé depuis 92 vos
visages sans groen et non à bimont
retour de plus en plus d'assurance et
tout je suis sûr qu'elle fera une belle
carrière latine visible ou pas ou plus
sérieusement c'est pas un mensonge
non pas du tout pas du tout ben si
thierry de la pressée que quand même à
la présidente en avait toujours des
idées à ses deux fils moi je vais vous
dire la céder leur aimable genre
d'émotions avec comme ça c'est la saison
des séries je ne sais pas vous caresser
les seins en venant ce matin
très content d'apprendre le prénom donc
ces jeunes viennent parce que nous on
est toujours plus que c'était madame
nancéienne j'ai pensé de sa plus belle
de fontenay elle s'appelle jeunes vient
de fort bien jeanniey bien au delà celle
là thierry gasco rire personne personne
ne rigole pas je mets des avions eu à
sortir à lui de la lys était écrit par
un de mes frères
voilà alors ça si vous avez si vous avez
pas tout casser suivre oui et que tous
des voix c'est terrible si vous avez un
livre à dire cette année c'est celui là
on a exagéré la lune et je les lui et
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir
non mais si non la fréquence est tombé
en panne d'essence oui au tce folie
voilà c'est le lilas alors ces termes il
faut dire la vérité qui s'appelle donc
geneviève et les siens qui est un peu
agi au graphique comme amap c'est écrit
par votre frère donc évidemment il ne
pas dire du mal de vous c'est votre
frère quelques petites scènes se
répètent adore fait très peu oui disons
notre famille s'amuse on s'entend bien
ouais vous entraider alors c'est la
chronique d'une famille française donc
c'est votre frère qui l'a écrit vous
avez fait la préface on se raconte
l'histoire de votre famille vous dites
que vous allez écrire la suite que vous
allez écrire le deuxième tome est ce que
vous pensez
selon à écrire après l'histoire soit en
ce sens le parfum et vous m'avez imbibé
de 2,2 quand il va rentrer chez lui ou
espèrent taper du c'est pas croyable
alors donc ce livre raconte votre vie
pendant que je parle serge khalfon si tu
veux mettre des photos où on voit madame
madame de fontenay en barboteuse
c'est donc vous est l'aîné d'une famille
de dix enfants nés
voilà voilà la bassée vous là ok skills
et xavier quitte à lui donner ces photos
là j'avais plus de ça aujourd'hui la
patrie là mais ça y est bon ça saigne et
linda linda l'orphelinat mend à droite
oui truc but jean xavier mareva georges
misse en savoie la lorelei acquis à
gauche et linda les inviter chez vous
aussi bien ce que c'est déjà d'être une
br derrière la passe qu'est ce qui
prouve qu'on peut se concevoir ce que
j'avais déjà les cheveux courts est
énormément
alors bon vivre dans une famille sa
série p surfer mais c'est pas clair ton
boulot c'est vous ça j'aime bien vous
êtes génial quel beau bébé alors
décapage ans et plus est la barbe et la
peep
voilà donc vous venez d'une famille
geneviève on n'avait pas le droit de
parler à table sauf au dessert pour voir
comment on est éduqué zola vous voyez
vous vous soignez vos parents c'était ce
n'était pas drôle la vie arrivées de
martine et aussi quand vous n'étiez pas
gentil a pas moins été accrochés aux
clowns sans frontières salue droit
martin est un peu seul quand j'allais me
cacher dans le confessionnal pour ne pas
avoir froid
évidemment c'était ça faisait pas bien
c'est pas les stigmates
est-ce que c'est du martinet de votre
enfance que nous viennent vos penchants
sado-maso de chance vous y croyez pas
que c'est ce qu'ils redoutent
là on l'écouté n'est vraiment vous étiez
une élève pas très brillante
il faut dire la vérité mais très élégant
dire que déjà qu'ils aient commencé à
porter des chapeaux
vous avez vu dans le livre à trois ans
j'ai déjà un petit bobo donc vous aller
à la messe avec un chapeau à l'école
avec un chapeau oui oui c'était assez
insolite surtout et vos parents étaient
obligés de vous changer d'école que je
sais c'est vrai bah non j'étais chez les
soeurs de la miséricorde alors un jour
pas marrant d'avoir un fils cadet jean
jouzel mire un abattoir est elle viable
si on peut l'appeler venir
quel support bon alors un jour un je
vous avais marre de tout ça hagondange
longue oui oui c'est tout cet enfant est
un droit de parler à table
le martinet du bien martin et je peux
vous le dire moi et la main je vous
avais marre et vous allez musée 2 euros
actuellement non mais c'est vrai alors
elle mangeait que le seigneur j'aime
bien et appelé à l' école
d'esthéticienne et là vous débarquez à
paris tout seul et vous devenez miss
élégance et là c'est la vie commence
c'est vrai que c'est mon destin bascule
et voilà sait jamais il a appris bien
j'ai même pas que ça existait les mises
comme étaient abondants alors comment
alors maintenant vous allez me dire la
vérité parce que la maman comment vous
avez fait vous arrivé à la gare de l'est
avec votre valise
et puis comment entre le moment où vous
arrivez gare de l'est d'hagondange où
l'ong women
comment vous y asseoir avant de
rencontrer celui qui a été mon compagnon
pendant 25 ans louis 3 mais voilà je
voyage et esthéticiennes chez antoine je
voyageais je circulais en bretagne
notamment je faisais des soins de beauté
et un jour j'ai vu à carnac avait
l'excentris carnac
jm des amis on va aller voir ça puisque
la première fois que j'ai entendu parler
de lui ce soir là que j'ai rencontré
celui qui est forte et là ça a été on
peut je crois qu'on peut le dire
ben non pas tout de suite mélissa car je
n'avais pas eu mon adresse et puis après
je suis allé à saint cloud et puis
parlez moi de lui et c'était un homme
formidable
mais tout a pris je lui dois tout j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration toujours d'aignan
du su rester fidèle au delà de la mort
et parce qu'il faut dire c'est que lui
est mort en regardant c'est incroyable
c'est rien qu'un tel homme politique
voyez à quoi le soir c'est dans sa phase
à giscard mitterrand c'était chiant ce
louis de fontenelle mari de geneviève
regarder la télé le face-à-face giscard
mitterrand il mange une tartine de
confiture
il meurt 16 mars 80 voilà la compagnie
allait mal tourner et que le terrain et
être élu c'est une façon c'était un
homme de gauche avait mis quoi dans la
confiote comme moi je prenais le bien
j'en suis très bien à elle dit ça c'est
comme ça que j'aime bien tu investis la
confiote barre mais j'aime quand
geneviève geneviève je connais le rush
imlin d'éloignement un bon fond c'est un
père de famille d'exemple et sophie
thalmann ma vie que vous étiez très
sympa et bon choix c'est un malentendu
notre première rencontre vraiment un
malentendu les dix tournois je suis le
seul à le voir à lui avoir caressé les
seins depuis combien de temps
wba giscard mitterrand tu veux y
retourner
oui mais après après l'émission d'accord
et sans ballon
bon alors face à tout le monde en parle
et rit la chaîne est récurrente
il ya les miss france voilà il y en a eu
beaucoup je vous le dis choisir entre
entre joue north
si jamais les multiples enquêtes y
présentera fokoua plus très bien ça va
pas de soi ça serait bien mis score ça
serait bien
bon ça on est peinard moi je suis pour
miss berry à la tête du rpr
une idée vous avez dit foucault parce
qu'à part à vous dites y'a pas le choix
c'est un jour noir et très bien être
guillaume durand préfériez pas guillaume
dunand pas du tout pourquoi n'ont ils
pas j'aime bien jouer il voulait pas
qu'ils nous nous en ont mais il est
beaucoup mieux que jean pierre kutwa ça
dépend pour quoi pas bon pourquoi je
l'aimé trop dit ou pas assez jolie
amenons j'éprouve
moi je défends ta gueule oui alors que
durant un jour j'ai rencontré mme page
proximités à roland garros n'est même
pas dit bonjour j'ai dit bonjour bio bon
alors il est il a eu peur d une photo de
lui quand on se trouve derrière votre
chapeau quand on regarde le moi je vais
lancer un appel solennel guillaume je
sais que tu es en train d'écrire un
livre en ce moment pour raconter ce qui
se passe vraiment à canal et attention à
vous de lépine et donc guillaume quand
vous viendra en parler j'espère on va
rien on va vous réinviter je voudrais
quoi je sers les consignes avec ma fille
je voulais qu'on n'avait jamais rien et
mais j'ai pas j'ai senti pour les deux
et j'ai roulé mais bien aux sommes déjà
à m la suisse y en a pour idole des gens
qui ont du talent bon penser que les
arméniens ont plus de talent que les
hommes en tout cas ces raisons nous y en
a trois bon bah merci je l'appelle le
titre du livre est ce qu'il y avait les
cia voilà c'est fait la promo montré la
voie là j'aime bien mais les siens donc
par paul newman
chers amis chers ennemis j'accueille
maintenant lou doillon
je sais ma première émission tout seul
alors je tripe un peu mais ça va on va
être très sympa mais déjà sa première
alors elle a devedjan la belle de
fontenay nous quand vous en parlerai
dans quelques années ou du conditionnel
et baffie déjà donc louve jouer dans un
film on va faire tout promo télé normale
vous allez voir propre vous jouer dans
un film qui s'appelle comme il fait gris
clair dans un film qui s'appelle
mauvaises fréquentations qui est réalisé
par jean pierre améris avec mode forge
et robinson stévenin maxime mention je
fais qu'une brique excusez-moi exemple
fasse ainsi l'épisode cas il fait ça
comme ça ça nous permet de ne pas rire
une connerie bête et faire ça parce que
trans milliers de rires ouais je suis
bien au coeur alors et reviennent à la
françois berléand et ariane ascaride
voilà et micheline presle alors
l'histoire vous la raconter je te
raconte tout
aïe
ouais c'est vrai ses deux copines olivia
et delphine l'olivier assez vous peut
être un peu des salles et déjà quand
même contrairement enfin par rapport à
delphine qui est plus plus sage oui vous
êtes un peu des salles et vous
rencontrer deux types dans ces deux
types ya un robinson stévenin et l'autre
mention s'appelle le ix e il fallait
leur ménager la jamaïque et pour gagner
le pognon pour se payer le voyage et la
jamaïque
il vous demande de vous prostituées à
vous et la petite delphine et vous vous
n'avez pas envie du tout vous trouvez
que ces imbéciles mais comme vous voyez
qu'elle est folle d'amour de ce type
vous allez avec elle parce que vous
dites si je laisse tout seul ça va être
encore pire vraiment glauque la gelée vu
le film je les ai vus il est pas mal
il est pas mal du tout s'énerve on
pourrait regarder la bande annonce non
ah ouais
[Musique]
l'art c'est oui la pince et on va
discuter c'est toujours bien vous avez
remarqué moi je le comprends mais tout
ce qu'on va en ce moment c'est le fond
mme arena maintenant tandis que tous les
mecs ils pensent qu'à leur cul c'est
pire
je pense à un truc c'est de faire mal te
baiser ici hier soir chez certains
garçons et je crachais rust ouais j'y
pense tout le temps
[Musique]
tous les mecs du bahut il pense tout ce
qu ils pensent qu'à ça
c'est tout ce que tu as trouvé ta peur
ce sens du film delphine on peut tout
faire par mois à 20 ans j'ai tout quitté
pour ton grand père pour m'était
complètement malade ça veut dire ça
s'appelle une chute ces cinq ans et
devenir une [ __ ] mais c'est toi le
pourri pourtant laurent boudoin trahi
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
messieurs thorax
ça ça soit on lan dur de potes j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] c'est pas pour toi qui
fais ça tu comprends ce pour delphine si
tu me manques fut le bienvenu que puis
dans mes infos que tu m'écoutes
séraphine on peut tout faire pour
voilà mauvaises fréquentations de jean
pierre améris avec lou doillon
alors lancez votre combientième film
j'en ai fait un tout petit avec enfin
quand j'étais tout petit avec agnès
varda quand j'avais 5 ans avec maman et
ma soeur et les filles est donc zappé
kung fu master et c'est ça elle 187 de
vie quel âge était pas je sais pas 4,5
entre comme ça je mens et après j'ai
essayé de faire un film avec mon papa
pour le jeune werther mais j'étais pas
formidable donc en fait il a coupé la
scène en film oui justement alors votre
papa donc on peut le dire c'est jacques
doillon votre mère c'est jane birkin et
donc vous devez tourner vous avez quel
âge pour werther content et donc votre
mère vous avez dit vous donner des
conseils de gnl vous disais vous faisait
répéter les textes en vous faisant le
poirier c'est ça comme ça elle vous
disait qu'il ya tellement de bordel sur
un plateau que si vous arriviez à dire
le texte en faisant le poirier vous
fallait rester concentré elle m'a dit
qu'on pourrait jamais faire une scène
sanquer raccord maquillage à la dernière
seconde
ou alors qui est un projet qui expose
quelque chose donc il fallait être sûr
de pouvoir dire son texte quoi qu'il
arrive et puis aussi allongé en écoutant
la bbc aussi ça doit pas être simple de
répéter sont actuellement gérés journée
en écoutant la bbc banon mais c'était
bien c'était vous à dire et jacques de
ce film no way ce que vous saviez pas
les dix phrases que vous dis à prendre
oui parce qu'en fait il m'a mais face à
la caméra il m'a demandé de parler en
regardant la caméra j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment sale ou de sa part donc j'ai
fait semblant de pas que du blues à il
vous a mis la caméra très prenait d'être
collé et j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
plutôt dégueulasse donc j'ai pas dit le
texte mais sur ce tournage du jeune
werther votre père de jacques doillon
vous à vous a traité un peu comme une
comme une figurante finalement et
pirouettes et vous vous dites mais c'est
mon père est une fête comme tout le
monde et là c'est là que vous avez
compris qu'il fallait pas mélanger le
business et le sentiment oui il fallait
surtout que ouais j'ai compris après sur
trop peu d'amour qu'on l'a finalement on
a fait un film ensemble ça c'était
carrément les dons que il a été super
rigolo parce qu'il aurait pu être
vachement proche de moi et j'aurais
sûrement l'équipe ados qui m'aurait dit
regarde c'est la fille de hillary pas
lui parler donc il n'a pas adressé la
parole
et moi je tends la route la journée donc
les techniciens venait me remonter le
moral en temps c'est un [ __ ] jacques
est donc en fait j'avais dit que
l'équipe de mon côté jacques il était
seul en train de se faire insulter
donc en fait c'était plutôt gentille
histoire vous êtes tellement charmante
comme envie de vous protéger d'eux alors
vous êtes actrice par vocation parce que
vous êtes né là-dedans vous avez fait
votre premier film à 5 ans vous vous
êtes vous sais pas trop quoi faire ou
est ce que vraiment vous vous ressentez
en vous une vocation d'actrice bah je
voulais pas être comédienne avant parce
que c'était un peu la raison pour
laquelle je voyais pas souvent mon papa
la maison mais je sais pas pourquoi la
première fois je crois que c'était en
lisant antigone d'anouilh où j'ai réussi
je suis quelqu'un de super excessive et
là j'ai réussi pour la première fois à
canaliser tout ce que j'avais dans le
jeu et en plus après on vous dit que
c'est vachement bien après un groupé
après vous appelle devenir hystérique
enfin c'est vachement bien communiqué je
me marre en regardant parce que je pense
que les gens chez eux se disent est ce
qu'elle ressent ma birkin est ce qu elle
ressemble à jacques doillon tout le
monde est en train parce que les gens se
foutent de ce qu'on raconte à la télé
faut le savoir les gens ils disent ils
disent fontenay 10 dont elle a toujours
son chapeau ardisson est de plus en plus
cons il disait ce qu'elle elle ressemble
à berquinois dwyer voilà un peu des deux
mais je pense que les oreilles de serge
gainsbourg ça je comprends bien alors
tant pis mais moi j'adorais gainsbourg
motors gainsbourg ça a été le pop je dis
sérieusement c'est une façon je suis pas
le seul à le dire tous les deux tout les
gens j'ai interviewé que j'ai reçus dans
des émissions c'était vraiment celui que
j'ai préféré alors dans le film il ya un
moment où l école ils écrivent comme ça
sur le tableau olivia et delphine sondés
sont des petites [ __ ] et vous aussi
quand vous alliez à l'école une des
raisons pour lesquelles vous êtes parti
tour de l'école c'est que on écrivait
sur le tableau comme ça lou doillon est
la fille de jane birkin donc ça vaut il
y avait une pression comme ça de moi
j'ai pas eu vachement de potes à l'école
quand j'étais qui parce que mes parents
ils voulaient pas me couper du monde
avec que je sois avec d'autres enfants
de comédiens et qu'on soit tout cela
bien la nesbe super donc ils mettaient à
justin raison dans les écoles communales
et tout ça donc ça c'était rigolo est
vrai patron me chercher à l'école pour
qu'on sache pas trop qui étaient mes
parents mais évidemment un moment les
gens ils découvraient et moi j'ai eu une
enfance vachement cacher donc dès que
les gens savaient qui j'étais il avait
l'impression qu'ils avaient un sujet
tabou et donc ils se mettaient tous à en
parler on mettrait du doigt et j'étais
une sorte de petit martienne quoi on
venait pas trop jouer avec moi parce que
j'étais la fille de et on les crimes au
tableau et on peut les carnets de
liaison pour avoir les autographes
dessus ah oui ah c'est pas moi j'ai pas
pensé à ça oui en effet
les carnets de notes les autographes de
deuxième but qui lui c'était comme une
otan française j'avais des bonnes notes
en français pour le reste il disait le
tableau le cartable
oui parce que birkin ça fait quand même
mal à passer des années en france elle
dit toujours le porte
après on s'en expliquait déjà avec elle
de ça à la télé elle reconnaît qu'elle
exagère un podium mais elle reconnaît
les deux demi soeurs a jamais plus voilà
moi ce soir j'ai encore les deux mois
qu'est la fiq que jane birkin a eu avec
john barry le fameux compositeurs
hollywoodiens grand talent il ya
charlotte évidemment avec avec serge il
y avait l'autre lola et après il ya les
lits du côté de mon papa on a tout et
non l inde accord jacques doillon appris
que des ailes
thomas dont les enfants je pense que dès
la fin manon milonga sais c'est que les
filles c'est ce qu'a décidé de coter
alors kate barry donc elle s occupe de
la réinsertion des drogués elle est
catholique
charlotte a décidé de choisir la
religion juive et vous bouddhiste quand
j'étais petit je voulais absolument une
potiche je sais pas je trouvais ça super
glauque d'aller prier pour pour
quelqu'un qui avait l'air vraiment pas
super gai sur une croix avec tu sens
partout et [ __ ] chétif et il n'avait
pas l'air facile en fait un copain mes
devoirs
ouais petit devoir bouddha qui avait un
sourire qui était très gros et qui est
quand même si sur un rack plutôt pas mal
pour montrer sa légèreté je trouve ça
tellement plus gai j'aimais pas l'idée
d'aller à l'église et de regarder ses
pieds pour avoir les choses moi on m'a
toujours appelé puis de regarder les
gens quand on leur parle alors là je
voyais pas pourquoi tout le monde
regardait en bas je trouvais ça plutôt
que vous avez dit en parlant de bouddha
c'est le seul qui n'a pas l'air de
souffrir je vais dire vivre souffrir que
la chance vous fait plaisir
alors jen dit en parlant de vous vous
êtes toujours été dit lou a toujours été
mon meilleur compagnon et c'est réglé
beaucoup accompagné danser dans ses
voyages dans toujours un peu denses et
les lancers je dis pas non c'est juste
parce que jane birkin est passé la
procédure avait toujours été un peu
denses et jean quoi et partout dans ces
grands manteaux elle me cacher donc je
dormais dans les brancards de pompiers
pendant les concerts non c'était cool
alors on disait tout à l'heure que vous
avez quand vous avez cette expérience
sur jeune werther jacques doillon vous a
traité un peu comme un peu comme une
autre pas comme une sa fille en tous les
cas vous avez dit j'ai ce jour là j'ai
compris qu'il fallait pas mélanger le
travail et les sentiments pourtant votre
compagnon fasse pas votre compagnon film
votre compagnon dans la vie vous jouez
avec lui dans le film me robinson
stévenin
ouais mais c'est une exception adacore
savait déjà que dans la vie on peut
avoir des grands principes et puis faire
beaucoup d'exceptions faut faire la
promo c'est pas tout tourner des films a
pris forme à en parler à la télé oui ça
vous embête
non mais je vais m'habituer bodmer est
devenu une star de la promo un oui je
sais c'est pour ça que c'est une des
meilleures clientes de la flamme si si
tu démarres et que thierry qui pourra
tout fait après ça c'est davantage mais
je suis gentil la route quand même très
petit quand même c'est beau c'est votre
côté un petit peu jane birkin à vous
êtes un peu rebelle quoi en disant vous
dites si demain la solution givet oui
moi je trouve que
je sais pas c'est compliqué mais j'ai
appelé la tête de mener de front sa
révolution avec elle non non mais c'est
parce qu'un je trouve qu'il ya un peu
trop de bordel et qu'un et que moi je me
connais absolument pas en politique donc
j'ai même pas envie d'en parler parce
que je trouve que tu compare les
politiques quand on quand on sait pas
vraiment s'il le fallait que je
l'attendais elle alors je viens à genève
lou parole là vous avez un homme de
droite non politique de droite à côté de
vous est ce qu au nom des jeunes nous
avons vu dire quelque chose qu'il ya
quelque chose contre lequel vous avez
envie de vous révolter jours à venir or
non moi je suis mal placé moi je sais je
vous voyez j'ai vu une émission sur des
jeunes de jeunes des cités qui justement
est mettez tous ensemble pour parler des
hommes politiques et chocs isaac plein
de trucs à dire et moi j'ai ils auront
honte de moi si vous avez dit que vous
sentiez plus en sécurité avec les gens
des cités qu'avec lac avec la police
ouais parce qu'ils y font chier pour
n'importe quoi donc c'est moi je sais
que le nom de l'arrestation que j'ai eu
juste parce que j'avais des dreadlocks
nous a insultés dans tous les sens j'ai
car ça c'est inadmissible
c'est vrai qu'il vous en ai dit enfin il
ya eu des tentatives dix ans encore vous
étiez au poste avec eux et ils ont voulu
quand même c'était pas au poste moi
c'était dans un rer et gérer un club qui
a senti son armée qui m'a remis sur la
tempe et qui m'a dit maintenant tu vas
déshabiller tu vas faire ce que je veux
et moi j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des
grosses cas dans le wagon d'un côté qui
sont mis en règle et là c'était la terre
parce que quand vous avez dit je vais me
plaindre ils vous ont mis à qui tu veux
pas la police puisque la police et nos
jours c'est toujours cette [ __ ] ça
c'est vraiment arrivé à lui celle
touchant le sketch de coluche et
d'actualité c'est toujours ça là vous
vous rendez compte
patrick je me rends compte cvac aussi si
on n'est pas révoltés à 17 ans en
matinée un gars qu'on qualifie kivu
français dans un wagon des erreurs même
si on a ça augmente on est révolté quand
même
500 votants pour ce salon tout en
mettant mon fameux flic mois d'une
révolte et entre artistes mais bien
entendu c'est un nom vous dit
à 17 ans nous révolter c'est normalement
fin quand même là y'a de quoi je veux
dire qu'au 17 ans ont pas quoi
certainement alors on va nous faire
comme si la première fois vous faites de
la télé et comme c'est la première fois
qu'on se voie mais bon on a pas on n'a
pas fini de se voir je vais faire plein
de films donc à chaque fois au ghana ils
ont raconté
on va maintenant demander à serge
khalfon de baisser les lumières
[Musique]
on bouge pas tant maintenant à voir
comment c'est normal refaire on rallume
alors j'en ai vu qu ont bougé est-ce
qu'on peut rallumer
voilà la tension dans le jingle on ne
bouge pas alors attention un peu 3
[Musique]
le premier souvenir
un souvenir avec mon grand père je dois
avoir 3 ans et demi et je suis cachée
sous une table ronde où il ya un trou
explique du saucisson c'est rigolo
le petit chat le saint boniface et
rigolo on est le père de jane
oui votre premier choc dans la vie votre
premier choc brutal des revers
je dirais sûrement la mort nos
grands-pères way qui est intervenu très
peu de temps ça a été accepté la mort de
mon grand père qui est à une journée
différence c'est sa première baffe mes
parents et moi j'amène ipaf j'ai juste
peur qui m'a mis à vraiment la gueule
mon père mais c'était en fait on joue à
mike tyson surligne j'en ai décroché
s'est calmée de secondes et il a regardé
par terre et j'ai senti que ça n'allait
pas trop bien et je lui dis pardon
apprenez s'est retournée chez moi c'est
ça assez des douanes yayoro jamais une
guerre pardon papounet bellion du doigt
votre premier objet fétiche
j'avais un singe un message non un four
ma maman elle a toujours eu un singe en
peluche et évidemment quand je suis né
m'a donné un singe et moi j'avais un
singe lui arracher l'oeil quand j'étais
tout petit et je l'appelle incarné
estrada saint-jacques premier péché je
crois que c'est quand j'ai dû way un
jour j'ai piqué sans mal à ma mère quand
j'étais tout petit pour aller acheter
plein bonbons avec une copine je crois
c'est une première crème des camions
dans les rues ouais moi j'ai fait ça
vaut aussi s'appliquer d'argent j'avais
acheté une maman votre nom
le premier amour la nasa va c'est le
fisc là mes amis de ma maman qui
s'appelait harry danger connaît comme
est amoureux tout petit 1,6 on était
ensemble sur la plage et il m'a dit
d'ailleurs si moi ce que je trouve assez
drôle que je faisais du chantage toute
la journée où je me cachais avec lui et
si mon bras c'est pas je jure les jeux
mettait à hurler plus personne fois une
quinzaine de membres à sa première cuite
rêvons à une nuit 14 ans 13 ans et demi
j'habitais dans les caraïbes
quand j'ai 13 ans et moins bonne saison
donc kamikazes est ce que c'est que je
me rappelle plus que c'est un fait ça
c'est la tradition gaz bourg les
cocktails le kamikaze est votre 1er juin
la même époque mais qu'ils ont été bien
ce voyage à saint barthélemy assez
chouette ça barde est votre première ex
tard pas c'est chouette ça dépend de la
ligue a atteint dirigerait je crois que
j'en ai jamais pris sauf peut-être une
fois on a filé dans un verre parce que
je crois que j'étais plus excité que
j'aurais que j'aurais été en buvant un
verre quoi je cours est un peu un poulet
sont donc là j'ai cru que je crois qu'on
le met quelque chose dans le vert vous
pensez que vous avez pris avec ce tas à
votre insu de ce qu'on a mis dans mon
arrêt je sais pas mais je sais juste que
j'ai couru dans tous les sens pour 1,6
et la grisaille deux étapes du tour de
france c'est parce que c'était la
première fois la preuve l'interview
première fois et tout le monde vous a
trouvé formidable passe au blind test
pour des lumières
bon attention didier est ce qu'on est
prêt à vous connaissez le principe du
blind test mais il connaît rien lui à
groland vous connaissez quoi qu'on
reçoit pas là on ne soit pas on n'a pas
du tout les mêmes chaînes de télé chez
nous connaît ma fille connais bien
entendu linda vous connaissez wc high
tech on va vous jouer des chansons
il faut reconnaître que c'est vous vous
êtes très fort en blunt est
mais si il ya une grève il ya un thème
si les animaux c'est parce que l'on ma
fille est ce que peu de gens savent
c'est que laurent baffie 15 au log
émérite et de rickshaw new marais pas
voir non c'est moi et surtout les gens
du blaye sur tous les animaux qu'il faut
découvrir laurent nous donnera le petit
détail un petit peu quand même
marie claude bomsel fait une chanson
française mais j'admire internationale
il ya beaucoup de chansons françaises
merde qu'on a commencé divier premières
chansons attention le premier gala
[Musique]
non non
dans le nord
alors quand il dit l'honorable est
évident que la chanson s'appelle le loup
lors là j'étais inquiète inquiète par
cette année des canidés mustélidés
mustélidés ses fils et la belette la
belette est un must et vous des way et
quelles sont les particularités du
mustélidés lors d'un animal un petit un
petit carnivore qui est très très
courant dans l'hexagone
beaucoup de représentants dans la chance
d'en apercevoir maintenant aux portes de
paris j'ai vu jouer les rôles audio
parce qu'il est trop de pie hat en série
la nuit ici à l'ap une pique à 6 heures
du matin au smoking vraiment ça va bien
on continue c'est beaucoup plus
difficile deuxième chanson didier ancien
il faut être fois voir l'âge de taper
comme ça va être très très dur a reconnu
bravo jg
est ce qu'on est
là je me dis merci des clones où sont
passées les gazelles africains de chair
humaine
bon alors là on a pris un point lou
doillon un point répondre à linda mais
moi je regarde vos fiches donc c'est à
dire que c'est une incroyable viande il
faut dire qu éric lagacé est un art you
d'actifs de la famille des bovidés c'est
ta famille des bolides et la gazelle et
c'est en quoi un artichaut dactyle c'est
le contraire de perry sodect il qu'elle
a un chiffre impair deux doigts de la
devedjian et change la vie sur toi là tu
es là le genre était rend cette espèce
il est quoi une prostituée depuis le
début de la soirée il te prenais pourra
mustélidés les baladins qu il dit ce
gars là est vachement ans avant didier
troisième morceau c'est pour nous et ça
j'aime bien voir
bravo
les secours
et un large sourire et chaussé de bottes
les traits comme ça pas de nuit envie
d'un riche en talent bien sûr monsieur
où est passé le toit j'ai dit tu
t'arrêtes le rendre quitté kid est tout
simplement
ouais didier s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
et oui quelqu'un
mougins moustiques dans l'ordre didier
comme on est en retard
la loue en ce moment c'est moins bien
alors didier contant retard tu sautes le
morceau suivant et tu vas au suivant les
requins les familles des quartiers
cartilagineux a cédé karting ils ont un
squelette nous élisons un squelette mois
et la rai la chimère font partie de la
même famille la chimère c'est quoi la
semaine c'est un une sorte de poisson
fait partie de la famille des quartiers
là j'ai une famille des balladuriens le
balladuriens cartilagineux ouais bon
saut de morceaux suivants
didier tension
pas du tout ils ont été blanchis la
terre
la maison j'ai passé
c'est la visite passionnante que sa
démission suivant 10 nuits
et en toile à l'est
je suis les doigts moustiques on le sait
très bien et est très bon l'éléphant ya
rien à dire
finnair proboscidiens la gestation de la
maman éléphant je crois que c'est non
ces 22 moins de deux mois sur la
gestation chez papa en gestation est pas
fort en gestation production chez cinq
heures de réunion qui commence à te
prendrais juste éviter tu dois savoir
dernier morceau le bonus track me
kiejman pour reconnaître j'ai juste pour
le plaisir d'écouter chanter
ça vaut
[Musique]
m
hu
[Musique]
dans la peau sont les loups dans l'eau
beurk
non merci le résultat je veux dire c'est
bouger les doigts les autres je pense
points le week-end passé le loup bien
non mais lui connaissait tous mais
souvenez pas les noms
ça c'est un trou tête-rousse vélo je
vous remercie beaucoup d'être venus et
ils s'appellent bonne fréquentation
jean pierre améris avec lou doillon et
robinson stévenin voilà j'accueille
maintenant mesdames messieurs quelqu'un
qui a longtemps vécu avec madame de
fontenay et ce soir je crois que ce qui
va se passer on n'envoie pas le jingle
didier janin parce que ce qui va se
passer ce soir est très forte
guy lux
oui
bonsoir bonsoir madame mademoiselle
monsieur bien qu'ils luxe bonsoir vous
m'avez je vais expliquer pourquoi vous
êtes là
d'abord parce qu on vous adore ensuite
parce que vous avez écrit une lettre il
avait écrit une lettre parce que j'ai
été choqué par non pas par votre
émission alors émission et par celle qui
s'appelait l'antenne interdite qui était
présentée par philippe gildas emma de
caunes ou guy bedos une fois de plus
s'est comporté à votre votre endroit
d'une façon un peu cavalière lyon nous
ont écoutés en fait on va pas en faire
un fromage
papa ça suffit on veut être la lettre ou
variétés violente quand même la seule
chose que j'ai regrettés c'est que
imagerie en mon absence support très
simple c'est une preuve de lâcheté mais
ça venant de lui ça n'est pas sûr pas
non et puis il est là
et d'autres pas ce qui m'a doublé amené
à vous écrire une lettre c'est que vous
avez aussi quelques problèmes avec la
même émission absolument absolument
l'avait gratifié d'une chose que donc je
me contenterai simplement répété
d'approuver et peut-être d'applaudir
c'est que vous lui avez dit que c'était
terminé pour lui que c'est un has been
du rire c'était un ancien du rire et que
je partage totalement cette émission
moussavi moi j'ai raccroché il ferait
bien de raccrocher beaucoup d'autres
devraient nous imiter à guy lux voilà je
vous ai je vous offrir un cadeau c'est
le groupe jalons qui m'a qui m'a envoyé
ça et je pense que vous en ferez bon
usage vous rentrez vous rentrez là à cet
endroit là donc c'est un tee shirt de
mon ami basile de coke
vous pouvez le 1 combien d'exemplaires
rien à moi j'en ai un je vous l'offre
ah oui ben je vais l'offrir à quelqu'un
d'aller le porter vous allez porter chez
vous pour faire votre jardin non je vous
le métier auquel jean louis pour arroser
les salades
puisqu'il est question de salades c'est
vrai à qui vous avez raison de temps en
temps je pense que tout ce qui m'a dit
ça n'a pas plus d'importance qu'une
mouche qui tombe dans une salade alors
voilà on oublie ainsi fait c'est pas du
terme c'est indique-t-elle j'ai été
pendant non je voulais simplement me
régler un petit peu mon compte avec ce
brave garçon way qui sait plus très bien
ce qu'il disputera bien ce qui fait et
qui ne sait pas très bien où il va oui
alors celui là ça y est je les ai mines
antichars
parce que vous ne savez pas concernant
minutes parce que il a inventé
évidemment intervilles tout ça je sans
frontières c'est moins sympa avant que
plein de trucs le palmarès une parade
extra 8 mai guy beaucoup de jeunes qui
lui en veulent à l'époque mais c'est
samedi symboliser un moment là l'un peut
symboliser la télé je trouve que tu es
vachement salou avec l'olympique parce
que j'aime bien le dow est ce que
personne ne sait qui c'est que vous avez
été dans l'est avec les prêtres ouvriers
ouais ouais mais ça vous rendez compte
de ça
guy lux et un moment avant sert à faire
lui non mais c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
dit il a été il avait 17 que l'âge où
j'étais entre 17 et 20 ans quoi vous
aviez envie d'aider les autres
ça m'étonne pas du tout ce qu'il dit a
beaucoup de coeur dont ont fondé par
lula non non pas du tout à ça ça risque
pas non fait je suis simplement heureux
d'être là pour rappeler deux trois
petites choses c'est que l'autre jour
lorsqu'il a fait cette déclaration dans
l'émission où je n'étais qu'un
téléspectateur devant l'écran il a dit
je ne voudrais jamais les pieds dans ses
émissions de concret
alors j'ai retrouvé des petites notes où
il a quand même participé au palmarès
deux fois admis non une fois à cadet
rousselle trois fois pour alors tu vois
guie guie tu as fait tellement démission
de maire de beira la mienne maintenant
la marche
déclaré une fois dans une mine cariou je
vous parlais de vos cheveux je vous
disais mais c'est vrai je veux pas vos
vrais cheveux vont expliquer l'histoire
du vercors la blessure etc et vous
m'avez dit voilà ce qu'on avait répondu
c'est historique mailly tout le monde
croit que comme bedos je porte une
moumoute vous c'est pas vrai si
maintenant c'est vrai sur partie sur la
jardinerie l'accident voilà donc donc
vous ne vous êtes pas changé d'avis
jamais vous avez un truc comme une pièce
de 5 francs là c'était là la blessure de
guerre dans le vercors dans la
résistance et vous avez dit moi c'est
pas une moumoute mais tout le monde
croit que comme de dos je porte une
moumoute voilà un laurent baffie à un
coup de chapeau encore un tir air 10
sous quand même parce qu'après avoir
tenté de revaloriser la droite va de
santé de revaloriser de guy lux b
absolument c'est de l'héroïsme ne sait
même plus tu aimes pas faire cesser pour
ça je ne peux tient un niveau des
sentiments tout le monde est toujours
très libéral puis après quand on laisse
en réalité alors si vous aimez les gars
ont bien anticipé à mon association pas
d'enfant sans vacances qui me permet
d'enrayer bon an mal an 10200 vacances
tous les enfants vous des gosses sans
jouer son bonheur sans noël et le 19
c'est une phrase d'ailleurs découvrir ce
que ces cas l'hippodrome il ya une
grande fête pour 1000 gosse qui
reçoivent des jouets tout le monde est
débile
j'enchaîne maintenant richy désolé guy
lux temps quand on voudra bouquin faut
l'ouvrir complètement à droite moi et
même sur ce conflit ah non mais ça vaut
gardent bon j'enchaîne conseil accueille
maintenant catherine fou
bonjour catherine bonjour laurent banide
à ce que l'annoncé
qu'est ce que c'est c'est de la poudre
casquette celle qu'a trident de mona
selon catherine il s'appelle catherine
avec la chine et les 4,4 alors vous
sortez de céder alors je vais me trouver
à côté parce que vous êtes tous un peu
dans le même dans le même muda je vais
expliquer pourquoi après quand vous
sortez deux cd il ya un qui s'appelle
des créatures l'autre qui s'appelle
l'homme à trois mains celui qu'on va
entendre après c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est vachement bien
fontenay mal à choisir c'est bien pour
la formation qu'ils descendent bien
alors catherine vous êtes né dans le
bocage vendéen
c'est vrai un petit village s'appelle
chantonnay soit des gens des petits
villages aujourd'hui philippe ménard de
barsac philippe katerine de chanteur a
dépassé la vidéo c'est journal s'est
même vu guy lux et la saison noah alors
vous êtes d'une famille catholique d une
enfance mystique un philippe bonjour
catholique en tout 40 ans voulait être
prêtre d'être fasciné par les icônes ou
me dit juste oui oui parce qu'on est
pressé c'est oui
ceci explique peut-être le style un peu
naïf un peut nier un peu les rythmes un
peu bébête de vos chansons
oui oui oui alors vous avez une grande
proportion philippaerts bêtifier ânonner
à faire un peu le simplet oui et ça que
j'ai mis à côté d'eux parce qu'il ya une
mode en ce moment de la crétinerie pas
une mauvaise affaire compagnie mode la
crétinerie gdc nous sommes des chrétiens
houellebecq il ya philippe katerine y
avoue c'est un peu à la mode de jouer
les guinéens peu laissée par la mode
basse il ya plus en plus ancré dans les
critères sont quand même tu préférais
oui c'est à des gens qui ne seraient pas
crétin qui jouerait être très tard et
vous c'est l'enfer et comme c'est la
mode des crétins c'est à dire peut-être
mieux mais c'est très bien on est ravi
alors vous dites l'idée même de
l'intelligence au service de la chanson
me fait fuir
ouais ouais elle j'aime ta wii cette
idée là
j'ai pas tellement d'exemples oui mais
bon je fais avec les moyens du bord
c'est je suis pas spécialement
intelligent intelligent je dis ça je
fais faute de mieux qua non mais
l'addition vous invitez c'est qu'on aime
bien votre beau disque comprend
maintenant on vous dit que c'est pas la
peine de faire d'être intelligent pour
faire de bonnes chansons c'est ça je
crois bon c'est pas incompatible non
plus mais
c'est pas nécessaire chers amis chers
ennemis maintenant là écoutez donc
philippe katerine alors il ya deux cdi à
l'homme aux trois bras ya un autre qui
s'appelle les créatures voilà zoom zoom
zoom zoom et le cdh et je vous emmerde
celui qu'on écoute maintenant philippe
katerine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aurais pu être millionnaire avec
piscine et vue sur la mer
mais qui suis dans la mer
jamais
sentimentalement démissionnaire
rationnellement suicidaire que tu vois
moi je suis dans la merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais
babel une amortie un taré pas
q est votre maman
ah ouais
et caresser aux singles en mai
suis une merde
ça emmerde
ouais moi aussi
vous
danser
mais pas sûr cependant
non
[Musique]
on
moi je suis un
[Musique]
le trou est fait ça
je suis en trop
a three
wet wet première fois
les patrons
sachant nuit
qu'est-ce que nous envient
[Musique]
tous les mois
et pourtant c'est une grosse puissance
thurella aller
tu chantes tu es
l'argent
[Musique]
épouse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
philippe katerine voilà c'est bien
alors voilà je vous ai vu beau marais
vous êtes marais avant soit un petit peu
aux chansons dont je dirais faisait
l'éloge at the selenites inquiet sur ce
que veut nous amener en 2000 battant des
lames du tronc à l'épaule c'est comme
antoine c'est aussi bien des gens c'est
pas pareil se passe bien c'est bien
mérité deux belges ouais
à côté il ya un côté j'adore alors le
dise qu'il va changer puisque les champs
là on a écouté je vous emmerde mais
notre chanson et le poulet numéro 7 128
120 aussi extraordinaire c'est un très
bon disque servir de vous plaire je vous
avolon qui joue le maintien et vous même
aujourd'hui je vous donne le petit croix
à l'elysée viiie ce fou qu un les
métiers vous comportiez donc on fait la
promo l'attention se calme patrick
devedjian le rpr donc si vous êtes rp à
voter pour lui
un ctp à tendance libérale un temps
danse moderne moderne société rpr social
national social non mais parce que parce
que les autres là vous n'êtes pas de ce
côté là je ne vais pas tout ici sociale
donc je vais appeler à voter pour donner
jones qui tutoie guy lux merci ce coup
de gueule était nous a revigoré tous un
bon alors j'ai les douars moustiques
benoît delépine donc à 20h20 sur le
guide de notre président solution
présentée par nagui et l'on ma fille se
rende
soir 21h 23h c'est quoi ce bordel europe
de europe 2 voilà linda hardy dit
tardieu prochain avec moi à coalinga
christ la semaine prochaine avec moi
merci à tous donc c'était tout le monde
en parle on se retrouve samedi prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]